a grand jury has indicted Daniel Penny
the Subway Hero on second degree
manslaughter charges now an indictment
is you know they say you can and you can
indict a ham sandwich it just means
there's enough evidence to go to trial
it doesn't mean he's guilty or anything
like that but it is a disgrace crime is
getting worse in these cities and the
policies enacted by the people who've
been historically running these cities
for a long time is only making them
worse and we've got the big Story coming
out coming out of San Francisco is the
collapse of their downtown district
several hotels have been surrendered to
their lenders and now the Westfield mall
has been surrendered to its lender so
we'll talk about how all of that lumps
together of course I've been talking
about it all day
Civil War
and I'll just say it here as as you know
we'll get into it later on in the show
perhaps we might not but you know
because we've talked about it quite a
bit Hillary Clinton mocking Donald Trump
as he's being indicted the first time a
president has been federally indicted in
the history of the United States Joe
Biden is criminally charging his main
political rival the GOP front-runner and
it's unprecedented is an understatement
I often say if you went back in time and
told someone hey this thing would be
happening at this point you know they'd
say oh you're crazy if you went back 10
years and said you know in seven years
there would be Street clashes all
throughout the United States there would
be massive rioting a guy with a with a
communist tattoo on his neck would shoot
and kill a conservative in the middle of
the street in Portland they'd say you're
nuts it's never going to happen if you
told them that January 6 would happen
they say you're nuts if you went back
three years ago four years ago and said
the president will arrest his chief
political rival they'd say oh is it
going to be Trump but people wouldn't
believe it's going to happen it's not
going to get that bad that's crazy and
now we are at that point so
you know we may we may end up getting
into that but I do want to talk a lot
about what's going on with these bills
targeting children because uh we do have
a very based story of kids in a school
protesting against their school for
trying to force them to engage in pride
month at a time when we're seeing bills
pass in California being advanced in
California I should say that would take
your children away from you if you don't
affirm their gender identity so we'll
talk about all that stuff before we get
started my friends head over to
castbrew.com buy cast Brew Coffee it is
our coffee company pick up rise with
Roberto Jr Appalachian nights we also
have a Colombian and French roast
available and you can join the cast Brew
Coffee Club where you'll get three bags
of coffee every single month and
supporting us through casper.com this is
our cultural Endeavor we're building
coffee shops it's all in the works it
takes time but with your support we're
going to have those physical spaces to
hang out in don't forget also to go to
timcast.com but if you click the link in
the description below timcast.com mobile
Dash app we have put up
the Android app on our website so right
now ladies and gentlemen you can
download the Android timcast app
iPhone's not available because you can't
just download Enough website like you
can an APK file
we're currently awaiting approval from
the stores Apple and Google play in the
meantime again timcast.com mobile Dash
app and you can download to your Android
phone the APK directly you know some of
these Android phones will have like a
block stopping you from installing an
Android file without changing the
settings or whatever so you may need to
look up how to do it but for now you
know a lot of people have been asking
when's the mobile app coming out and
it's like well it's been done it's been
done for months but we're waiting for
Google and apple to allow us to put it
in their app stores so I figured we will
just put those up while you're there
click join us become a member directly
uh sign up to become a member to support
our work at timcast.com and we're going
to have a members only uncensored show
coming up for you at about 10 p.m and it
will be based and spicy so you'll want
to check that one out you'll even be
able to call in if you've been a member
for at least six months or you sign up
at the 25 per month level so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends uh
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this and more is billboard Chris
thank you so much for having me Tim uh
who are you what do you do so I'm a dad
of two girls from Vancouver Canada and
for almost three years I've been
traveling around North America and now
the world having conversations on Street
about what I consider to be the greatest
child abuse scandal in modern medicine
history
which is the transition of our kids
my expression is there are two Sexes
zero genders and infinite personalities
our children are beautiful just as they
are
and no drugs or scalpels no drugs or
scalpels are needed to help them be them
their true selves we should leave them
alone let them grow up and so I have
conversations about this right on well
uh thanks for joining it should be fun
we got Sheamus hanging out yeah and
thank you for coming on the show excited
to talk to one thing I just want to
mention this idea of a true self right
it almost always means a false self when
the left says it they're trying to
change the child into something else but
I'm Sheamus Coughlin I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes I make
cartoons there we're going to be
releasing one tomorrow I think y'all are
going to enjoy it it's about Donald
Trump being put on trial so if you guys
want to go over there check that out
support the channel go to Freedom tunes
and hit subscribe yeah I'm very excited
to see you again Chris it's been a while
been maybe over a year but uh you've
been had some hot activity I've been
watching from the sidelines so it's
quite enjoyable it's been wild yeah man
can't wait to hear about it dude got uh
Mr Duprey on my right over here yes uh I
am here it's gonna be a good one
pleasure to meet you Chris and uh I'm
ready for the episode when you want to
all right here's the first story we got
grand jury indicts Daniel penny in
Chokehold death of Jordan Neely Neely's
death was ruled a homicide according to
the medical examiner they say the exact
charges will not be unsealed until Penny
appears in court at a later date the
sources said Penny was initially
arrested on second-degree manslaughter
charge okay so to clarify the uh I I
thought they had indicted him for that
reason so we don't know exactly what he
was indicted for but he was arrested for
a second degree manslaughter video
showed Penny putting kneeling a
Chokehold on May 1st several witnesses
observed nearly making threats assistant
district attorney Joshua steinglass told
the judge some witnesses told police
that Neely was yelling and harassing
passengers on the train Authority said
police source told ABC news that Penny
was not specifically being threatened by
Neely when he intervened and that Neely
had not become violent it had not been
threatening anyone in particular Neely
was homeless at the time of the incident
so there is another witness on the train
who said that he was threatening all of
their lives saying he was going to
seriously hurt them and that she thought
they were in serious danger and that
Penny saved their lives but this is
what's happening in big cities so it's
unsurprising to hear that they've
actually issued this indictment the fact
they arrested him in the first place I
have questions about these police
officers I have questions about
you know where this where this country
goes if this is the case we had that
story that we talked about and we'll get
into more detail with San Francisco's
downtown district being totally
obliterated and I want to show you this
tweet this is a tweet from Ellen Barkin
Ellen Barkin um I'm not familiar with
you know what her career is I think
she's a writer or something but she just
responded good
so you have people who live in New York
who every day are facing serious threats
of violence as the city is Rife with
crime
I Google searched and I hate to be a
little crass but I Google searched rape
on a New York a Subway
if you Google search that you will see a
ridiculous amount of stories almost
every week something like that happens
it is shocking to me that there are
women in New York City with all of that
going on every single week and they're
celebrating the fact that someone tried
to help people to save people from a
violent dangerous individual
well I mean none of these people have
any ability to look more than five
seconds into the future in their General
world view is
if something makes me feel positive
happy emotions it's good if something
makes me feel negative sad emotions it's
bad and so hearing about somebody
intervening and saving other people's
lives potentially but knowing that that
cost the aggressor their life might make
somebody feel negative in the immediate
short term and so then they're going to
try to find a rationalization for that
negative emotion because they don't want
to challenge it they just want to stick
with what they feel
and similarly when you have these
stories of people being harmed of course
you've mentioned this before Tim that
there are people who are pushed in front
of the subway this never becomes a story
right when there's completely senseless
violence or when a woman is sexually
abused in public it doesn't make
headlines the same way that a man
defending citizens does and that's for a
very simple reason because the media
wants us to know that if we stand up for
ourselves against violent criminals we
will be punished for it I mean this is
by Design they want criminals to overrun
the cities they want to make life as
untenable as possible because this is
something Marxist virtually always do
when they're trying to upset the social
order make things as unstable for people
as possible
just generally make cities unlivable I
suppose it's like the ice cream shop in
Seattle that's suing now because their
business suffered a loss of Revenue when
the autonomous Zone the Capitol Hill
autonomous Zone Chas was established but
the same ice cream shop was calling for
them to defund the police that's right
yeah that was that was a good headline
ice cream shop that supported to funding
police is now suing the city because the
police didn't help him it seems like as
I often say it's a chaotic and
destructive force that is its intention
is just to destroy it I I can't I can't
put myself in the shoes of these voters
of people in New York City people like
Ellen Barkin who are like I'm glad
that people are stopped are not allowed
to defend themselves it's like Bizarro
America you know it's like it's like
intentionally nonsensical illogical and
destructive but yeah what the left has
effectively done is it's gotten people
to cheer for the prospect of
defenselessness right so we're going to
defund the police and then we're also
going to prosecute you when you defend
yourself and we're going to do
everything we possibly can to ensure
it's as difficult as possible if not
impossible for you to get a firearm to
protect yourself or your family and we
know whenever the left is in control of
of anything things don't get better for
people I think one really hilarious
example of this was the Capitol Hill
occupied protest or autonomous Zone
depending on how you want to refer to it
where leftist literally took over
several city blocks in Seattle and not
only did no one in the media call it an
Insurrection but ironically enough this
was done in order to protest police
violence
and then over the course of this being
set up two teenagers were shot in this
autonomous Zone that they set up so
they'll try to pursue these insane
utopian Solutions without actually
knowing anything when they're trying to
implement you know these Solutions
without actually doing anything that's
going to improve life for people but
just trying to shirk off the authority
that's already there and then when
people get get hurt they're never held
to account for it because they had good
intentions in what else matters when I
used to talk about the escalation of
conflict in this country and the risk of
Civil War 2017 there's an article in uh
New Yorker I I went back over that
article today because we just saw the
president federally indicted by I'm
sorry the former president uh future
president perhaps uh very likely we saw
Donald Trump indicted federally by Joe
Biden so this is a president targeting
his political rival
that's the highest level
that's it
what I was saying back then was all of
these conflicts that we're seeing this
political conflict it will reach higher
and higher levels of politics and I was
told that I was crazy that I was wrong
it wasn't going to happen now what we're
seeing and the reason I bring this up in
this context is the people that are
celebrating
a former Marine trying to save lives
celebrating his criminal indictment
arrest and charges when he was trying to
protect people is
it's it it seems
like opposite day it seems like an
inversion on American morals and values
it seems like literally Bizarro America
yeah this is what happens when people
are led by their emotions and not logic
when they've given away like you look at
the pictures of this NBC is it NBC or
ABC ABC News article there it shows
Daniel Penny bad guy I mean he's got
handcuffs on he's got five o'clock
like looks got Shadow on his face then
you scroll down and you see the the
other guy though oh yeah homeless guy
look at this glamor picture like this is
the guy that was screaming he was going
to kill people on the subway uh but man
you're not gonna know that by looking at
that beautiful picture of him with all
that really nice lighting and the city
in the background
um so I think what happened is this guy
walked on the train I was like I'm gonna
kill so and but he wasn't specifically
targeting any one person and that's the
that's the argument they're making but
he was obviously yelling and making
people uncoverable enough that people
felt like they had to intervene
apparently stop this guy before he
started apparently they all went to like
one side to avoid him like he was
threatening that isn't common maybe not
commonly New York Behavior but that is
like if you have ridden a New York
Subway you know when the guy starts
screaming that smells like poop down the
way you get up and you move otherwise
he's going to come sit on you
well these are people who say that words
are violence and misgendering somebody
is incitement and then this guy is
screaming that he's not afraid to go
back to jail and he'll kill somebody so
and there was no need for anyone to step
in and neutralize that threat it's it's
patently ridiculous on its face and
you're right Ian they're showing uh
they're showing nice looking pictures of
the person who was an aggressor and
they're showing pictures that make the
defendant in this case look as unlikable
as possible every single time there's a
story of a police officer shooting
somebody in the news the media has this
Unwritten rule never show the mug shot
never show a picture of this person in
police custody always show them when
they were younger always show them in
their most attractive moment and then
this guy's on trial and of course they
have to represent him as uh some kind of
violent maniac and not someone who did
something reasonable and tried to help
people so they're showing you pictures
where he doesn't look at it it's they
they show a photo of Penny In Handcuffs
looking at scowling right they show the
perpetrator the the person who who was
the aggressor with a glamor shot in City
Lights it's probably 10 years old too
yeah absolutely my question now I'm
sorry this once so this yeah
it feels intentional it is it feels like
the media intentionally wants to gut and
rip apart and Destroy and the legal
system is playing the lap dog of the
media whether it wants to or not like
they don't want their careers to be
ruined I bet Daniel Penny's lawyer was
like don't say anything in public about
it but I'm wondering if you posted a
video Daniel Penny did yes he I haven't
seen it yet was it an emotional plea
because if he hasn't captured people's
emotions yet I feel like he's doomed to
the legal system but if he can get out
ahead of it and start making internet
videos nope then maybe like the guy
sorry there's questions about whether or
not people in New York on a jury will
actually convict him because they're
probably going to be like there will be
regular people saying I experience this
no way we can't configure this guy but I
have a feeling that after a few of the
uh riots and antifa smashing windows and
setting fires after a couple of those
then the jury will go in under armed
protection and just say I just want to
be left alone I'll do whatever you say
yep yep I mean there's a question that
the United States has to ask itself um
and I'm taking this from a conversation
that I I had on my podcast the other day
and it actually didn't uh come from my
guest it came from him paraphrasing a
book that he'd read recently which
unfortunately I don't remember the name
of but you you really have to ask
yourself the question who are you
rooting for right and whenever you look
at these stories whenever you analyze
anything the media is talking about
whenever you're looking at a public
policy prescription you have to ask who
is this rooting for who is this helping
who do we care about well take a look at
this story from the New York Times
Westfield gives up gives up San
Francisco Mall signaling more pain ahead
retailers have been fleeing the city's
downtown and some analysts say there may
be more to come it's an issue facing
various downtowns around the United
States I love how they try and once
again obviously what's going on it's
it's affecting everyone yeah no um the
Hilton and park 55 massive hotels in
Center San Francisco being surrendered
to lenders and a massive Mall which is
several hundred thousand square feet
being surrendered is regularly unique to
San Francisco maybe it's all of the
human feces littered about the streets
or the rampant open-air drug use but
this city has been gutted and destroyed
and the question to ask is
should we be happy or sad about this
should we glout haha look what your
policies have wrought why even though
these policies are destroying these
cities you still have these liberals
cheering for it so maybe we just say
okay then you're getting what you want I
suppose they are I I still think there's
reason to be sad about it because this
is something that is being destroyed by
people who didn't build it and that's
always very important to remember this
city was built up by their parents and
grandparents and great-grandparents and
then they came along and they tore it
down and part of the reason they tore it
down was out of Envy there are people
who have worked harder than me who have
made more beautiful things than I've
made or could even hope to make or am
interested in making and that makes me
mad and I want to rip it all apart and
so when they start to do that by
implementing insane policies that say
things like you can steal and we won't
prosecute you as long as it's less than
nine hundred dollars worth of theft
that's occurred
and you rewire people's thinking into
this very insane short-term
um Paradigm that rewards people for
taking and not for making then this is
the exact scenario you end up with you
get destruction and nobody builds
anything why would they you've only
punished them for it can we go back to
when they passed that that law in San
Francisco where they were like or I
don't know if it was a law or a policy
or whatever anything under 990 or
whatever you would not be criminally
charged if you stole and then we
immediately started seeing videos of
people filling garbage bags full of
merchandise well I guess because none of
them none of those items equal up to a
thousand dollars so they would just
start dumping entire shelves into bags
hop on their bike and then ride out and
everyone just shrugs why wouldn't these
people keep doing this
if they get arrested they get let out a
couple hours later and they can go right
back and they do this 20 times yep and
then when I have these employees at
Lululemon who reported on or tried to
stop the they just filmed it they just
filmed it yeah and they got fired yeah
just for filming because the policies
don't intervene they went outside like
father I'm filming or something like
that well it didn't write I've mentioned
this a hundred times in the show but
anytime someone's doing something
degenerate immoral or destructive we
have to engage in every level of socio
economic analysis to excuse their
behavior they were only stealing from
that store because we didn't spend
enough public money on the library in
their neighborhood or they didn't have a
good enough public school but then when
these people filmed someone who's
stealing something from their store
which is an abundantly reasonable
reaction to people committing an act of
theft in front of you they're evil they
have to be fired there's no mercy we
don't engage in any kind of analysis of
their behavior we just dispense with
them you look at AOC cheering or or
demanding the criminal Char the Char
charges for for Penny saying that oh it
was murder so a murder happened in
public how is he not getting it's it's
wild they're creating the problem
they're exacerbating the crime and then
they're trying to imprison and destroy
the lives of anybody who tries to
protect themselves they genuinely don't
want you living in these cities and
where does this all come from
we have communism being rebranded yep in
Western culture yeah a lot of this stems
back to Karl Marx it's the same policies
it's the theory that there is class
Warfare there's an oppressor class and
there are the oppressed and a lot of
people
when you're talking about this with
normal people it's not probably good to
talk about communism because they look
at you sideways like you have a hole in
your head and you're some conspiracy
theorist
but Marxism
has been rebranded to be equity and up
in Canada where I'm from we even have
the conservative leaders calling for an
equitable Society well Equity is just
equality of outcome that's not what we
want we want a quality of opportunity
if Martin Luther King were alive today
they'd be calling him
the black face of white supremacy just
as they did with Larry Elder in
California because he was calling for
equality of opportunity but he would be
aghast at what's happening today I mean
but we're also talking about the Civil
Rights era back in the 50s and stuff so
he's fairly conservative on a lot of
issues and uh I don't know what his his
religious background was obviously he
Martin Luther King yeah obviously he's
Christian but I don't know which which
sex is the Baptist Baptist yeah I mean
just that alone makes him a fascist
right a Christal fascist right if you're
a Christian today you're a crystal
fascist I get called up all the time
people assume I'm a Christian I'm not
I'm basically agnostic
but I deal with these crazy people all
the time these violent people I've been
arrested twice after getting assaulted
just because it's easier to get rid of
me than it is to get rid of all the
crazy people I've been saying that we
had a um press for truth Dan Dix was at
a was that a protest do you know the
story that's me that he was filming oh
he was filming you and then they they
pulled him I'm the guy that got
assaulted and then they removed him they
said you got to get out of here and they
pulled him out and threatened him with
the rest that's happened to him as well
right they he was confused because he
was recently just interviewing me when I
was assaulted and then they threatened
you with the rest or did arrest you no
they the main police officer who was
there to investigate a previous assault
that already incurred smiled as I was
getting assaulted wow and this video had
80 million views that went all around
the world wow Dan was just a couple
months ago but I've also been arrested
after getting assaulted twice in
Vancouver uh Dan was filming a protest
they attacked him the police then come
in and they say you have to leave and
he's like me he's like they attacked me
and he's like don't care you get out now
or you're gonna get arrested it happened
it happened I've been telling people it
happens to Street Preachers as well in
Canada the police the police are going
well look at that preacher in um in
writing Pennsylvania do you see this
story no there was a pride event
happening and a guy was in the street
and he just he started to quote a Bible
verse and the cop just grabbed someone
arrested him oh I did see that because
the cops are thinking it is easier to
arrest one person than deal with a riot
that's right yeah yeah absolutely but
it's good it's great when they do that
because it's backfires
backfires every time I got charged with
causing a disturbance after getting
assaulted by a union rep actually of the
British Columbia government
and I was hoping it would go to trial
because this would have been a slam dunk
Victory but of course one day before my
course hearing the charge gets dismissed
nah in the meantime I was banned from
walking on all these streets in the
middle of downtown Vancouver
but all it does is bring in more support
for the cause so it backfires every time
and we have to I mean we have to expose
this every time but we have to also take
it and use it in our favor
as we have been doing and it's working
people are waking up finally to what's
going on in Western culture yeah you
just worry though and I think there's
kind of in intellectual and governmental
arms race occurring which is the left is
trying to become as powerful as possible
and get as much leverage over the
average person before people wake up to
what's happening right ideally for them
everyone hasn't woken up to what they're
doing and what they're trying to do
until it's already too late and they
have all of the Power so we have to get
as many people as possible informed
before we get to the point where they're
literally able to do whatever they want
and it's getting close I mean it really
is getting very close and my biggest
concern for all of this is the
universities because that's where these
kids are really getting indoctrinated
yeah yes a lot of them have left as
parents or whatever but they get into
these universities and these are
indoctrination stations now I disagree
okay I think it's tick tock
I think it's Val for sure yeah I mean
it's in high schools too gradually for
the younger kids I think kids are
starting to to push back but I think you
know I've had this debate with uh Dr
Peter bagosian who shares a similar view
to yours that this this stuff originates
in universities and I think a component
of it does but I think social media
algorithms have perpetuated this the
reason why we're seeing so many
companies now backtrack and panic even
like you know everyone's saying oh ESG
is driving this stuff and I'm like I
don't think so I think this stuff is
driving ESG or there's some correlation
but not a direct causation Target saying
they wanted to hide their pride
merchandise in some stores the bottom
line is everything and if their cost
benefit analysis is we make money when
we do Pride stuff they'll keep doing it
now that the Bud Light thing happened
they're starting to say we actually are
going to lose a lot of money if we do
this so just stop doing it what's the
point so I think that's actually a very
promising sign I do think there's
something turning around here and I
think we are on a major path towards
victory yeah I've been hearing some
crazy stuff like people who are
completely outside of politics posting
things on YouTube and stuff and saying
like hey man I'm not cool with this
people are repeat me well no it was me
yeah but yeah what is it I used to be in
the investment Arena I used to have a
real job before I was a crazy billboard
person standing out on the street
getting assaulted and arrested but crazy
bill it amazed Me That Wall Street
essentially was captured by communism
because that's as capitalist as you get
yet we have ESG coming through the back
door and you mentioned ESG and
why is ESG capturing Wall Street well
ultimately that even comes down to
communism because you have firms like
BlackRock managing this 30 billion
dollar pension fund or whatever it is in
California
and you get the leftist politicians
pressuring BlackRock that if you don't
start pushing our agenda we're not going
to let you manage our gigantic pension
fund
so ultimately
they bow down to some of these pressures
and they start in turn putting these
pressures on the companies that they
invest in otherwise they won't invest in
them
and when it comes to investing it's all
about the institutional investors that
these corporations care about they don't
care about the retail investor it's all
about the institutions and so kind of
through this back door they've gotten in
there but all this is coming from so
many directions it's the weft it's the
who it's the U.S well I mean the
activist organizations exist but what I
see happening is
when
it was about what's socially acceptable
and what's not before the internet
racism is not socially acceptable
any like most bigotry hates speech on
stuff people are like hey we don't want
to do that because it can cost us money
if I'm selling Donuts at my donut shop
the last thing we want is for someone to
feel unwelcome to stop buying from us
that simple component along with the
1964 Civil Rights Act which enshrined
civil rights created algorithmic
pressures you end up with social media
running two different worlds right away
one was nationalistic one was
Progressive
the progressive one seemed to be more
socially acceptable because it was in
line with movies in Hollywood and things
like that the nationalistic one seemed
to be conservative so it's no good so
what do they do
Facebook almost immediately starts
having conservative stories pulled from
their trending news tab that was the big
the big breaking Revelation from Gizmodo
then they start from like 2007 2008
start actively promoting as much as
possible things that were socially
acceptable
so companies started mass-producing
articles that just played the social
justice game because that's what was
getting promoted and that's what made
them money
so if you've got a kid who's nine years
old in 2009
and they just get on Facebook for the
first time even though that's what
you're supposed to be 13. but let's say
they their parent got him a cell phone
and they found a way to get on it all
they see every day are videos of black
people being beaten by police why
because it made money for corporations
that's the only reason media websites
made money off of it that kid nine years
old it's only thing he sees
now he's 23. his whole world growing up
the only thing he ever saw was these
kinds of videos
then you end up with that video where it
was Nuance Pro I don't know if you saw
this one Nuance bro is having a Twitter
space with this gen Z for change guy and
the Gen Z for change guy said 30 percent
of black people are killed each year
like just by the police
a number so insane Nuance Pro is like
that means all black people would be
dead in three three years or so are you
nuts and then he the kid goes would you
agree that 15 to 20 is more is more fair
and then they're just dying laughing
like have you lost your mind no they
never had it
that's why long story short I think it's
the algorithms that are manipulating
these kids into believing this
fictitious version of the world and then
you end up with a lot of people saying
they're delusional or they're crazy and
I'm like no no no no no there's a
difference someone may be suffering a a
disability a an ailment developmental uh
disability is absolutely different from
a kid growing up and being lied to their
whole life yes the problem with society
today so we think we're this Advanced
Society I said this on a video the other
day that took off a little bit when
talking about the transition to kids
we think we're this Advanced Society
technologically and all that we are yet
psychologically we're the same as
cavemen used to be our minds are very
malleable we're prone to group think
we're prone to mass psychosis
and now you bring in social media and
these algorithms and it's so easy to
manipulate vast swaths of the population
and that is what's happening and you say
this isn't necessarily coming from the
universities but all these people
working at these social media companies
a lot of them became radicalized and got
pushed further left while they were
going to University and then they get
these jobs Facebook was built at a
university yes by Mark Zuckerberg while
he was at the University but why is it
in you know pre-2016 you uh Twitter is
the Free Speech wing of the Free Speech
party and then all of a sudden it starts
to change that I think may have been the
result of the election of Donald Trump
you see that video where Google
executives are crying saying I can't
believe we let this happen and things
like that why is it that in the early
days of these uh uh these these websites
these media companies that were getting
traction the one I often cite is
mike.com which is you know woke
Progressive when it started it was Ron
Paul libertarian because it wasn't and
these are the same people who went to
University who started these companies
at the time held very different views
and then it changed I think the reason
is over a long enough period of time if
the pressure is on conservative view bad
liberal view good then you end up with
hyperpolarization towards the liberal
and the Banning of conservative ideas I
don't think there's anything to do do
with universities universities
theoretically should take generations to
indoctrinate a society you you're there
for a few years you come out and then
you're you're dumped right back into
society spending a few years in an
induction indoctrination Center you come
out you have those ideas you try to then
apply that pressure to the rest of the
country which is millions hundreds of
millions of people you may you will hold
those views but it's not going to be as
pronounced because you can only go so
far but why are conservatives so
hesitant to express their views because
I go to universities and hang out on
campus for hours days at a time
and I have these conversations about
child transition or whatever and I have
a sign that's very basic it says
children cannot consent to puberty
blockers
the conservatives have to hide their
views they come up to me in silence I
can hardly ever show our conversations
well that's that's just cowardice
but
but this is just the way it's set up
you're allowed to have these radical
left disputes but but you're not allowed
to have a normal view we call them
conservative views no they're not even
conservative they're just normal but
this is exactly what I what I was
explaining right it used to be back in
the day that all of our information and
our narratives came from television or
radio newspaper but mostly TV that's
where we absorbed everything and so you
had a small handful of networks that
dictated what was so we all basically
agreed on what was it was socially
acceptable now what is allowed to be on
the Internet is what is socially
acceptable and now what is allowed to be
on the Internet is actually changing it
it gets heavily censorious it goes back
and forth YouTube changes policies of
course these big tech companies have
gone very very woke Elon Musk buying
Twitter has started to change the game
on what has allowed rumbles emergence
and started to change the game on what
is allowed because these companies know
they'll collapse what I think is
first cowardice
and bravery they don't mean that you are
or are not scared bravery is when you
are scared you act regardless of your
fear cowardice is you don't you do not
act because of your fear right and and
I'm not saying to be a dick to people
I'm saying it is people take people are
offended by being called cowards because
it is a negative connotation but if you
are too scared to say how you really
feel how you how you really which
because you you know then that that's
cowardice and if you are offended by
being called that that I think that's
internal to you right I think someone
who refuses to act in the face of fear
and danger despite knowing that they
must and that there's important things
to be done is cowardice seeing someone
facing like you know the enemy troops
are coming in and they drop their weapon
and they run full speed knowing they
needed to defend their Homeland or
whatever we call that cowardice bravery
and heroism is knowing that you might
die in the great battle in World War II
but you charge those beaches anyway
because you have to you have no choice
that's how we Define these things I I
feel bad for a lot of these people who
know that they could lose their job jobs
could destroy their lives who could
destroy their families but the reality
is if every single person just spoke up
it would there would be no power there
anyway right the issue I believe is that
majority of people are only acting based
on what they feel is socially acceptable
what is the quote unquote right side of
history and the reason why now we are
seeing companies back down with the
because of Bud Light you know we're
saying Starbucks the workers union
saying they're being told to take pride
Flags Pride decorations down but the
company is denying it I don't believe
the company the major corporation was
worried about their stock price or their
bottom line the workers are ideological
and there's videos of the decorations
being taken down so that seems to be the
more likely but you know who knows who
knows all of a sudden now we're seeing
prominent personalities come out and say
hey I'm not okay with this more people
are starting to speak up why the Bud
Light effect showed people
mathematically and definitively
there is a large faction of people in
this country who do not like what's
happening when the sales drop by 30
percent and it persists for now two and
a half months you start to see people
say is is it cool now to do this well
here's what happens the people who
started making videos about Bud Light
start getting millions of hits now it's
definitive now if you're a regular
person you don't know what's up and
what's down all you know is amen when
they make fun of Bud Light they get
millions of views I want millions of
views right that's the social pressure
and the quote-unquote right side of
History right now we're starting to see
a major shift and with movements it's
never the leaders who are the most
important people it's always the first
followers because those first followers
make it okay for other people to come
along and that's exactly what we're
seeing today in Canada that this last
week we had the biggest protest against
gender ideology in Canadian history
led by myself and a student a 17 year
old boy who got kicked out of his
Catholic school because he stood up for
some girls in his school who didn't want
boys in their bathroom and he refuses to
yield
with to his scientific factual belief
that there are two Sexes so he got
kicked out of Catholic school but he's
leading a movement with students and now
the Muslims are getting involved
Christians were finally coming out we
had hundreds of people there whereas two
years ago I couldn't get two people to
come out on the street and we're seeing
this all over North America now and it's
not going to stop let me jump to this
story from the post-millennial to give
everybody a good bit of optimism quote
my pronouns are USA Massachusetts Middle
School tries to make children wear
Rainbow clothing for Pride students
Revolt wear red white and blue this
video is fascinating where you have
parents Furious that these kids were
saying no to Pride day some kids were
chanting that their pronouns were USA
they were wearing red white and blue and
pride decorations had been torn down
parents said the hate starts at home
this is fascinating so kids at a school
revolted against what the school is
trying to impose on them and other
parents came in and blamed the the
parents of those kids I gotta tell you
that's fascinating to me kids acting out
and you're Furious and upset but you
know what is you know it is amazing is
that we're seeing more and more of this
there's another video where kids are in
a classroom and they play a pride video
and the kids all Boo and groan and say
why are you showing this to us and the
teacher threatens them with a quote
unquote Saturday school if they if they
don't stop acting inappropriately
I think the kids are all right I think
we're seeing this is this is cause for
hope the kids are all right the kids are
more than all right and I've known this
for a long time because I'm out on the
streets and they come up to me but I'm
going to read you guys the message I got
from a grade 10 student today
hi Chris thanks for getting back so soon
oh here it is I'm in 10th grade this has
to stop
I'm tired of going to school scared of
getting pressed because I said something
bad in a language they made up it's not
fair that they're insecure teenagers
whose parents didn't give them enough
tension who knows if that's true but as
kids why do I have to pay for it and he
told me that in advance of this protest
we had last week over the PA system to
the whole school
they said
that if kids didn't get support for
Pride or for transition that these kids
would be likely to commit suicide or
have self-harm
a child said this over the PA system to
the whole school this is the propaganda
that these kids are receiving everywhere
and when they hear this a thousand times
a year they believe it and so when
People Like Us come along and talk
Common Sense they've been so
indoctrinated by these school systems to
believe that kids are coming to harm
that they think we're the devil but
they're planning a walkout the students
now are planning a walkout next week
against their own where is this at this
is in Ottawa Canada oh wow wow but this
is happening all across the country in
Nova Scotia on June 1st 33 of students
didn't go to school the parents withheld
them to protest pride month whoa really
it's a massive yeah I mean Canada is in
serious trouble big time yeah but we're
fixing it I white people all the time
because I have faith in humanity and I
know that we're going to get the truth
out there but yes I think we're probably
the worst in the world if you like
children especially have a kind of a
you know just a reputation for being
um like uh to
am I having a trouble with the words you
know like to say no to uh revolt against
Authority there's this whole like Punk
Counter Culture yeah whatever's popular
children are are great young people
because their brains are still like very
open to seeing what's real and what's
not now there are kids that will get
manipulated but I tell you if a school
for a year force-fed kids meatloaf and
all they did was put meatloaf propaganda
all over the school you better believe
that half a bunch of those kids are
going to be like screw Meatloaf I don't
want I don't want anything to do with
meal if I hate meatloaf and then you're
gonna see that with pride it's not that
it's because they hate transgenderism
gay or by they don't want to be
indoctrinated exactly they went too far
popular thing I've been bamboozled by
this 20-something generation who love
government Authority wear masks you're
evil for not wearing a mask get jabbed
do everything the government tells you
that's what all these 20-somethings are
doing yeah but I'm seeing a generational
shift with the younger kids they're
tired of this and it's beautiful well I
wonder if it's because as we often
mention conservatives are more likely to
have kids and I think one of the reasons
the left is so panicked and desperately
trying to indoctrine in schools is
because they know they don't have kids
20 years ago it was like four to three
for every four conservative kids there
were three liberal kids and this means
that voting patterns are going to shift
very very very heavily now people on the
right often say Well they're going to
bring in illegal immigrants for that or
whatever and I'm like yeah but they
can't vote they they can change the
census in a decade which will favor
certain urban populations that do this
but in the short term they will not win
if this is the case right older people
are are passing on younger people are
entering voting age and there's more
younger conservatives than than left
conservative I'm sorry than left kids
and so they their only option as the
saying goes socialists don't have kids
they have yours that's their only option
yes and I've had probably 15 000
conversations out on the street my
number one allies I hate the word Ally
the people who support me the most
are black men yeah it's so rare for a
black man to have an issue with my
message which is that we shouldn't be
transitioning kids they all agree with
me the women too and Hispanic
communities and they are they are
conservative when it comes to family
they like the nuclear family yes well
you know but they've all been taught to
believe that they have to vote Democrat
as though Democrats are representing
their interests and they're not and
we're going to see a shift in this as
we've already seen happen in Florida it
is a it is a a fascinatingly white
liberal family thing to not have
families you know if you look at uh
we've talked about Shabbat and Jewish
families and how powerful that is in
protecting your kids your family and
your community from Friday sun down to
Saturday on Friday sun down to Saturday
sun down you are with your family you're
not working you're not you know they
Sabbath very seriously and uh even for
Christians going to church the these
form protective barriers for your
community from outside influences that
seek to destroy you but if you look at a
lot of uh like immigrant families if you
look at as you mentioned black families
they're they're very much so
they say that the church is heavily
involved in politics although it's not
as true as it used to be it is
fascinating that it seems to be more so
white liberal families that are opposed
to family in general it will it's um I
was going to touch on this and you sort
of mentioned this to him but these are
the views of a very specific subsection
of affluent white people this is not
something that the black community is
calling for the Hispanic Community is
calling for and it's not something the
vast majority of white people are
calling for either it's just a very very
small uh minority of very affluent
people and when you look at BLM in the
fact that they've tied it up so closely
with this gender nonsense and they've
even put a black and brown stripe on the
pride flag to try to link these perverse
sexual lifestyle choices to being a
minority in this country becomes obvious
that they really know that they have to
try as hard as they can to get the
support of these groups and so they're
going to try to do that just by claiming
it's the case and shouting you down if
you disagree with them having a few
spokespeople who are Black Or Hispanic
when in reality those communities they
don't like this right they don't want to
be called late Kinks they don't want you
trying to trans their kid they're not
taking their kid to drag queen Story
Hour this is something white Suburban
mothers with too much time and money
think makes them special that's all
that's affluenza I mean I thought it was
a joke what was that guys affluenza was
yeah no regard for consequences some kid
rich kid hit uh and killed somebody
drunk driving I believe and they let him
out and they're like wow his problem is
that he's too affluent he's got
affluenza that was an actual thing like
it's not an actual medical condition but
they purported like it was and I'm
wondering if that's this is actually
affluenza when people get too rich and
white and I'm white people get too rich
too rich like what's what will be the
word not too white but too like socially
stable complacent yeah complacent
because it's like oh you don't have to
work to be get ahead and Society did you
start looking into the problems it's
it's that uh it's that Meme of the guy
he tweets uh uh in the and he lives in
Los Angeles and he tweets yay they're
writing keep it up look like watch the
building burn then the next day he
tweets oh no they're coming to my
neighborhood get out of here you you
beasts yes this is the party of empathy
as soon as the problem is out there you
realize all this inner crap is not that
important look James O'Keefe did this
was fantastic they went to I believe it
was James it is they went people's
houses and they said that they were
people who were in favor of gun control
and then the people in the house are
like oh that's fantastic like do you
support gun control like I do absolutely
and they're like you don't own guns
right they're like no who does like can
we put aside in front of your house
saying proud proud gunless home like we
oppose guns and every person goes well
well no no you can't do that like you're
inviting criminals like what what do you
mean I thought you were in favor of gun
control that's the perfect example the
wealthy uppity people who are protected
by police will complain about police
because they don't see the problem
then later on they go oh Heaven's me oh
how can this be like that uh was it the
ice cream shop in it was Seattle I think
you mentioned they say defund the police
and then they go out they start losing
money and now they're suing the city
because the police didn't help him yes
I've had police called on me 150 times
Always by police people who say let's
defund the police yeah every time
they're the first to call the police as
soon as they see an opinion they don't
like no words for violence you know well
there's there's a certain kind of person
this happens to but I find this is also
true of people who uh are wealthy and
particularly when they're very wealthy
to the point where they will never have
to worry about their material needs for
the rest of their life there is an
increased emphasis on reputation and
other people's perception of you which I
think would be considered extremely
unusual if it were seen in a poor or
working class person
and what you no longer have to concern
yourself with having your basic needs
met how you look to other people becomes
much more important and so what happens
is you want to be seen as high status
within your community but everyone else
is already very wealthy or have their
their needs taken care of and so one way
that you can signal your superiority is
by saying I care about X Y or Z social
cause and even if you're not necessarily
doing anything that actually helps
people if you claim that you are if you
say you know you're contributing to some
cause like BLM which doesn't actually do
anything besides destroy but purports to
help uh black people and others who are
disenfranchised then you can get this
unearned social capital and I think
that's what matters to them more than
money in many instances let's talk about
the White House here we have the story
from the Daily Mail they are not your
kids DeSantis and musk slam White House
for Pride tweet celebrating lgbtq uh Qi
community and quote our kids that are
part of it in the post it says these are
our kids not somebody else's kids
they're all our kids that is
unbelievable I mean I shouldn't say it's
unbelievable it's predictable but that
is like they're just openly is saved by
a part loud it's it's obvious because
they're not Liberals are not having kids
they're aborting their kids and in many
instances now they are sterilizing or
increasing the the likelihood of
sterilization of these kids but what
kind of creep says that right of
somebody who knows that their political
faction doesn't have voters yes but this
is my point they're not just saying it
you're right they're acting on it but if
if anyone else like if somebody came up
to you in public and said those aren't
your kids those are our kids how would
you respond to them I would show them a
picture of the Communist meme with Drake
pointing to go like this to my kids and
then pointing to our kids I would call
the police
yeah someone said your kids are mine
yeah
our kids are mine I would I'm not sure
if I'm able to say on air what the I
would ask I would ask but I would ask if
they live in a housemate of candy
they're passing legislation in all sorts
of blue states to make this a reality
right where they can take California
away from you if you don't agree that
your girl is a boy that was California
something through the House of
Representatives I think into their
Senate hasn't gone through their state
house yes it's now Advanced to their
state senate in California
and they're saying that if you don't
affirm your child that uh they could
they could restrict visitation or take
custody of your kids yeah they consider
it child abuse they're already a
sanctuary state so that
if there's a custody dispute going on in
Texas for example and this mom wants to
transition the kid she can take the kid
to California and California will now
ignore all court orders subpoena's
arrest warrants or custody agreements so
that this job can be transitioned or a
runaway as well so they'll hide the
runaway from the parents and they won't
return them home so they'll ignore the
laws of the home state which should
violate the constitution this needs to
be challenged and this is this this is
reminiscent to me of the American Civil
War when they had The Runaways I think
with the Runaway Slave Act you had uh
states in the north saying that we will
absolutely not abide by these uh by this
law and the South saying then why are we
a part of this Union southern states
were like if we have a law then and you
don't follow it what's the point now the
circumstances of course are different
the moral questions are different I'm
wondering what the major Catalyst will
be maybe it's abortion abortion seems to
be a direct 14th Amendment uh question
in this country and uh 14th Amendment
violation in most regards so I wonder if
that'll be the Catalyst but I also kind
of think you know I don't know if the uh
transgender kid stuff will be the
Catalyst and it's because I listened to
audio from Matt Walsh of a father saying
they took his kid away and we're putting
her on cross-sex hormones
and it's like he's upset about it and he
doesn't want it to happen but that's the
extent of the action that he's taking
right I feel like when it came to John
Brown when it came to slavery you had
active Conflict for a decade of people
killing each other over the stuff that
you don't really have right now in any
of these social issues yeah well I think
there's a few so I hear what you're
saying about this not necessarily being
a potential Catalyst for massive
conflict but I also think that when
you're talking about people's children
it's just a question of how many kids
you do this to before somebody gets
violent it's going to happen you're
right they I guess they haven't landed
on those people who are going to respond
violently to them but it they will
eventually no no no no no I'm not
talking about uh civilians I'm talking
about government
you're talking about like at the state
level at what point do does the federal
government or law enforcement say
you must return the child under the code
of the law and then California says no
and then troops will have to be sent to
California to enforce the law
when when where you know so I you know
people give out for all sorts of things
and we definitely don't want that but we
need we we want civility we want peace
and at this point I think violence
actually just empowers them because it
terrifies people and they're able to use
terrorism as a weapon yeah I'm saying
like at what point does Texas say we we
we are demanding the return of this
man's child to California and California
says we're not going to answer your
subpoena like you said they're gonna
they're gonna ignore subpoena's warrants
Etc
at what point does is how can there be
an intervention does Texas then petition
the federal government saying we need
federal assistance to to enforce these
laws between states what will likely
occur I'd imagine is a lawsuit under
original jurisdiction going to the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court might
just reject it outright and say we're
not going to listen to this and then
you're going to have Texas be like we're
sending the Rangers we're going to send
law enforcement to California to
retrieve this man's child because we
have the force of law behind us and
these people have committed crimes
California is now harboring criminals
what point do states actually send law
enforcement after each other yeah that's
a good question I've how does this all
go how does society go so this is a big
question
because it seems we're so divided almost
irreparably so
and each political party
really Stoke division the media of
course Stokes division
it almost seems irreparable I think
we need an extremely strong and truthful
and compassionate leader who can Unite
but that's almost impossible as well
with this social media age but
I'm an eternal optimist and I do think
it's possible but I don't really see
that person Trump winning
is he uniter
there's no uniting
there's only weeding out corruption
so
was reconstruction after the Civil War
in the United States unit uniting the
country
now you can argue it was but it was
brutal I mean getting rid of slavery I
think was Paramount and it was good that
it was done
but if you hear the stories about how
the Civil War went down what the north
was doing in the south I mean it's
brutality it's Untold I mean it's it's
it's horrifying uh Sherman's March to
the Sea the ransacking of Civilian
property the destruction of everything
in his in in his path just because
they're like we're gonna win and we're
gonna destroy it it's scorched Earth
if Donald Trump gets elected
and these states openly defy the federal
government
insurrection
he will then cite everything they've
said about January 6 and Insurrection as
his justification for sending the troops
in to enforce the law in these
jurisdictions
as as the federal government dictates
now the funny thing is the right who is
currently saying we want smaller
government the government's oppressive
will find themselves behind a more
oppressive government what worries me is
is that the Trojan Horse to get
federalized a federalized United States
in that the federal government now is
local law enforcement right we've talked
about this during uh the Summer of Love
riots
we don't want the federal government to
be local law enforcement we want states
to have their own jurisdictions
especially when it comes to things like
Roe v Wade the states have the rights to
decide what their laws are
if California is allowing the kidnapping
of children and they will defy subpoenas
and the rule of law outright because
they assert that their their morals
their legal code supersedes anyone
else's then the only option is for
federal law enforcement to intervene to
uphold these laws if Texas issues to
subpoena the federal government says
like we're going to have to make sure
you you can't do these things so let's
talk about Portland because Portland is
to a certain degree a lawless Society
police have orders to stand down if
antifa are committing violent assaults
against people
now for me we cannot live in a society
like that we cannot allow crazy mentally
Disturbed anarchists to determine how
our societies run but this is how it's
being run in Portland so recently I went
to Portland State University stood
outside
with my signs with Peter begosian Dr
Peter Goshen and the incredible James
klug I don't know if you know him yeah
of course he's amazing
dudes a pro but we specifically went
there because
that's the one place the one place in
the Amer in the United States of America
I was a little afraid to go to and you
cannot let fear stop you from doing
anything so we went there we planned it
out we didn't announce when we were
going beforehand because of course
antifa will then have time to mobilize
because he can get killed there but we
went there in the morning we stayed for
a few hours got amazing footage and we
left and I think we showed people that
we don't need to let
these anarchists tell us where and when
we can't have conversations because
they're not anarchists but why doesn't
the federal government move in there
well so just to clarify they're not
they're not anarchists they're they're
hardcore authoritarians and communists
right yeah like well they think yeah
they think they're Communists put them
in an actual communist system and
they'll revolve they'll lie to you and
tell you they're anarchists because the
idea Anarchy literally means uh lacking
or without Authority that's how they lie
to you they come to you and say we don't
want to be in charge we're anarchists we
don't we think there shouldn't be a big
government by the way do as we say or
else that's they're tankies they're
commies they're authoritarians all the
way but it comes from the mayor and the
governor there this lawlessness so do
you think the federal government should
intervene to restore the rule of law yes
I don't disagree but I also think that
can lead down a dark path when you have
people who live in California and say
these are our rules these are the laws
that we've passed and now the federal
government comes in and with national
Guardsmen patrolling neighborhoods
military police and federal law
enforcement Federal uh I guess they'd be
civilian law enforcement
telling people that those laws don't
matter anymore that that they're the way
they vote it doesn't matter imagine the
inverse but it's going to be a state in
this Union you have to abide by
some Collective Agreement but they have
their own within their states right they
keep voting for this they're celebrating
Daniel Petty being Penny being indicted
imagine the inverse Joe Biden sending
National Guard into Oklahoma to enforce
abortion at any point saying your laws
violate National order so we are going
to enforce like the the point is you may
think you're right
certainly we here on this show have our
own opinions uh and I think we are right
but if you zoom out and look at the
picture holistically you can simply say
faction a faction B and what powers can
they wield and if we assert that we are
right so we should be able to go into
their state to enforce our rules on them
regardless of how they voted they would
assert the same right and then we just
hope that we win yeah I look I
understand there's a lot to this and
it's not just
I'm not saying we should I'm saying
Trump should get elected and Trump
should go in I mean federal law and and
supersede these governments they're
violating the law in Oregon it's not
like they're following their own rules
they're violating the law and no one is
doing anything
to bring these criminals to Justice they
won't even stop them committing the
crimes they won't even stop them
assaulting people when the assaults are
happening the police will just stand and
watch it they'll arrest you if you stop
the assault there's a there's a video of
cops and they'll arrest me for getting
assaulted yeah yeah there's a guy being
threatened by a bunch of antifa with
weapons and the cops run up and grab and
arrest the victim it happens all the
time and then they apologize to antifa
saying sorry about that yeah
so yes I think that uh you know I'm not
an anarchist I'm not a uh Big L
libertarian Eileen libertarian on most
issues but I believe the big questions
about how government is supposed to work
is actually Collective uh largely
Collective morality we here in this
country have a uh judeo-christian moral
framework for the most part even the
atheists and agnostics in this country
do as I often mention Bill Maher being a
great example he may not understand why
he believes in the right of free speech
or the right to a speedy trial or a jury
of your peers and uh innocent until
proven guilty he may not understand why
he holds those values but if you study
history if you study the traditions of
the United States and where this
morality comes from and the legal system
going back to the Magna Carta Etc you'll
be like wow
these people were all very Christian and
learned these lessons from the Bible I'm
not saying you need the Bible I mean
Sheamus May disagree I'm just saying
that there's a route to where this
morality comes from and if you go to
Eastern countries like China their roots
on morality are very very different
so that brings me to the question of how
do we successfully run a country United
States when we're dealing with a
multicultural democracy and a
constitutional republic well the
Multicultural democracy is basically
breaking into our constitutional
Republican trying to supplant and
subvert it we must defend ourselves from
that and that means that if we have a
moral worldview and a moral framework
that for the most part we agree upon we
act upon that not under this guise of
codified logical legal code the the the
I come to this conclusion
because we were talking about Florida
and parental rights do does a parent
have a right to determine what medical
treatment their kids do get or do not
get do you think parents have the
absolute right
yes with very few exceptions so where
I'm from British Columbia we have a law
called the infants act which essentially
states that parental approval is not
needed for any medical procedure at any
age provided the doctor can understand
the doctor thinks it's necessary and the
doctor thinks the child can understand
and what happened a year or two ago a
father went to jail his name is Rob
Hoogland because he spoke out against
his daughter's transition which he was
powerless to stop the endocrinologist a
man named Brendan Hirsch sent him a
letter saying he could be a friend an
advisor to his own 13 year old daughter
but he couldn't stop her from receiving
testosterone
now the only Ray that law would ever
make sense for me is in the case of
maybe a Jehovah's Witness who won't
allow a blood transfusion because their
child's going to die yeah and they'll
let their child die in that case I'd say
sure intervene but in almost any other
circumstance I don't get it so the
reason I bring this up is the left's
argument is that parents should have
final say over What treatments their
kids get and that if you know the the
child wants to get a a you know a sex
change surgery or whatever that the
parents and the doctor decide the
government shouldn't intervene but
parents don't have the right to abuse
their children
and I'm not argument I'm saying the left
argues this position while
simultaneously arguing the government
should be allowed to mandate children
receive a medical treatment I.E the
vaccine conservatives have an inversion
conservatives argue the government
should stop a parent from trying to give
their children a sex change under the
arguments you just made it is it is
abusive and at the same time the
government should not be able to apply
by a mandate on a vaccine I am not
saying one idea is right or wrong what
I'm saying is there are different views
under the very similar parental rights
argument and of course we we on this
side will assert we are actually right
and we can write down the logic of that
But ultimately when it comes down to
explaining the principle of parental
rights you run into a simple question
when is where is the moral line for you
when do you say the parents are abusing
their kids and not giving them treatment
well obviously for us a child sex change
is abuse no question the left doesn't
see it that way therefore the principle
of parental rights means nothing all
that matters is the moral question that
we agree upon and if that's the case
then I believe this country should be
run on what is our Collective moral
framework and we must defend it
I just want to say one thing
I use this the expression the left all
the time it is the left we're pushing
this but it's not all the left most
leftists agree with us on this
when I was at Boston Children's Hospital
last year I had a protest there
were 200 antifa people on the other side
of the street there were about 10
parents standing with me
eight or nine of them
were lifelong Democrat voters moms
who know that they're girls or girls and
not boys now the mayor of Boston mayor
Wu said that I was a white supremacist
on a tour of Terror wow and they're
standing with me were a bunch of
lifelong Democrats the far left has
taken hostage the entire left because if
anyone on the left speaks up about any
of this they're then deemed a bigot
their anti-lgbt these four letters that
paralyze people they're kicked out of
their political parties so all the
normal leftists I say normal leftists I
don't agree with many of their
ideologies at all but the the moderate
leftists aren't allowed to say anything
it's really this 10 of the party that's
taking the whole party hostage but look
here I am banging on the door of the
right wing begging to be called a
conservative but Sheamus keeps calling
me a liberal PBS this guy's a liberal
over here
Sheamus has made the argument on this
show if you are pro-choice you can't be
a conservative yeah I I think that's a
weighted issue yeah I I don't think that
you can be a conservative and be
pro-choice that's such a fundamental
issue to the parties in classical terms
you're liberal where yeah word Liberty
comes from the Latin libertad meaning
freedom but now the left says the word
Liberty itself is a dog whistle for
fascism that's right not even not even
the classical sense not even the Phyllis
philosophical sense if you look up
traditional liberalism or social liberal
liberalism this country you'll be like
that actually sounds like Tim a whole
lot this is where Democrats were for a
long time so these people you're
mentioning they're probably very much in
a similar political space to where we on
this show are yet they call this show
conservative they call me a conservative
commentator despite the fact that I
argue with conservatives all the time
yeah especially on issues like this yeah
I'm called the far right but I'm pretty
Centrist it depends on the issue well I
also think it's hilarious that you
referred to as a white supremacist on a
tour of Terror because it's like they'll
just say anything they'll just say
anything no
no I've seen a bit of your work but I
haven't heard much
politics for me how can they even claim
white supremacists is this just because
everything fits under the alphabet soup
label and so if you oppose that stuff
you're a white racist
because you're white yeah yeah so that's
it well hold on hold on brilliant oh so
you must be scaring you're a supremacist
and you're white therefore get it yeah
at Portland State this
Professor he's a geology Professor he's
an Adjunct professor he came out to
counter protest us on his bike standing
right in front of us so I couldn't talk
to people and then he took his shirt off
his sweater off to reveal that he's been
on estrogen
now this guy said that we were white
supremacists and I said hold on what
what makes me a white supremacist he
said well look at you I said well you're
white
so his explanation ultimately was that
transphobia is the tip of the Spear of
white supremacy
oh yeah I was at Occupy Wall Street and
they were trying to figure out what
their main goal was going to be and
they're talking about the banks and the
corruption and then in exasperation some
guy stands up screaming at the top of
his lungs how do you people not
understand fracking is everything just
furious fracking and I'm just like yo
fracking you're like cutting the Frack
down okay fracking has nothing to do
with this president getting elected and
like but this guy in his brain the only
thing it could process was fracking he
thought the president was only elected
because big oil companies were investing
and those would allow fracking and that
the reason why climate change is
happening is fracking the reason why
there's social disorder is because these
big oil companies that was the center of
his Universe it was the only thing he
could comprehend very much like this guy
his whole world is trans issues so any
argument is the most Paramount problem
the world is facing yes these leftists
would sooner have us import oil from
Saudi Arabia than produce it ourselves
yeah yeah well that's what they think
how dare you that's right I mean we
can't drill in the United States because
when we pull oil out of the ground and
burn it that's bad for the environment
but when we burn oil other people pulled
out of the ground that's good for the
environment well how about we just say
when we create completely emission-free
energy nuclear yeah they also don't want
us doing that either it's almost like
they just want to neuter energy
Independence or something like that like
they don't care about our country and
want to fail Ireland is about to kill
200 000 cows
yeah that's demonic that's just insane
just kill all these animals meanwhile
China opens a castle-fired power plant
every week yep yep have you ever met a
cow
I've seen some you know know I I don't
know if I've met like been introduced
but I've seen some cows pretty close
like Bill Gates has developed a drug
he's patented a drug a pill to give to
cows so they'll produce less methane
that's gotta be
real for them
that's super healthy cow oh my gosh
ultimately I think we need to go back to
something that are called Nations
because this whole globalist thing isn't
really working out we need to pull out
of the World Health Organization we need
to pull out of the U.N we need to pull
out of the world economic forum and
start governing our countries like their
actual countries amen well seaweed-based
feed to reduce methane emissions in cows
it's just like okay how many levels of
scam do you have to be on to be able to
sell people pills to make their cows
fart less I got a better idea we should
get we should make helmets for cows they
go over their heads and they have a pipe
that goes down right in front of their
mouth but at a good distance away and
their butts and there is a fire so when
they burp it goes and now the cows are
breathing fire that would actually be
really cool could you imagine you're
walking down you're driving down the
road and you see a bunch of cows and the
cow looks and goes we just have to find
a way to harness the power of that
methane yeah so you know what you know I
was saying is we should get a big dome
and put it over the cow pasture so all
the methane gets sucked up and then we
used to to warm our homes that's a
really good idea do you think the
pendulum's swinging back to him
absolutely I mean I think the Bud Light
effect is the main it's a Bud Light was
a catalyst and now we see the Bud Light
effect all these companies panicking
over potentially getting boycott you
know Netflix lost millions of
subscribers oh yeah it wasn't just Bud
Light this stuff is happening I think
look someone like me right grew up in
Chicago moderately liberal individual
traditional uh socially liberal person
I see a pride parade I go whatever I see
pride flags and stuff I'm like oh that's
cool I have friends who wave the pride
flag on my good friend I'm glad you're
happy man congratulations I uh I'm I'm
fairly liberal in the traditional Sense
on issues of gay marriage and uh
families and all that stuff and I've had
arguments with conservatives on these on
these issues we get along but we
disagree
then all of a sudden I start seeing them
send books like genderqueer to kids
which have overt sex x in them from an
author who outrights says in the book
that she has sexually aroused the
thought of being a man and then wants
children to say affirm her as a man I'm
like I'm putting two together two two
and two together here
yeah they're grooming kids right now all
of a sudden I'm like hey can we not do
this and what happens they attack me
they call me a conservative
so this is this is the point where
people like me who are traditionally
liberal are now hang out with
conservatives and the simple way to put
it is this I am I am beset on both sides
by activists
on the on the right there's a man saying
I think abortion is wrong life begins a
conception and we should not be killing
these babies and I say okay well there's
a lot of challenging questions there
around the rights of of two individuals
now who are sharing one body and how we
deal with that but uh I hear your
argument right then I look to my left
and they say anyone for any reason at
any time should be allowed to abort the
baby even if the baby can can survive
and I say that has no logic and makes
literally no sense in any capacity if
the baby must be delivered from the
woman no matter what why kill the baby
they made this argument about like what
if the baby's stillborn was on abortion
then if the baby's already dead what if
the mother's health is in Jeopardy I
agree the baby must be removed I'm sorry
if the baby would survive abortion
specifically defined by by the federal
government planned Paradise ending the
life of that baby so what ends up
happening is a person like me who has
traditionally been pro-choice says if
the only options you're giving me is we
ban abortion outright or we allow babies
just did it at nine months to be killed
I'm gonna vote for the guy who's Banning
abortion because I'm like it may not fit
my world view perfectly but man that's
graphic and psychotic and they're doing
it in so many states now we come to the
question of child sex changes
look you take a look at what's going on
in Europe you take a look at Finland and
you know better than I do they are
shutting this stuff down the research
isn't backing it up and so I say okay
well you know the best assumption I can
make is clearly this doesn't make sense
uh it's not working and you look at
desistance rates these studies that
we've said in the show several times
show what is it 65 to 95 percent of
children desist and live happy normal
lives so there's an important thing
about that statistic this is based off
all the studies up until about 2004
before they started giving kids puberty
blockers so these studies and there's
about 12 academic ones that have been
done I'll point to yeah over 80 on
average
of these kids desisted but this is when
one out of 30 000 were affected and then
go through puberty this would yeah and
they go through puberty puberty itself
was The Cure yep now we're blocking the
Cure but this is real gender dysphoria
this affected mostly boys not girls most
grew up to be gay what we're seeing
today totally different mostly
adolescent girls they're all going to
grow up to be fun so here's my point
yeah well not if they carve whatever
whatever argument the left wants to make
about their views on these issues
something maybe I could potentially
agree with let's say they're like we
want to
um tax the rich
and I'm like oh man you know I don't
know it's universal healthcare we want
to create a public option and I'm like
there's a lot of questions about that
but I'm not you know as polarized on
that issue and they say vote for us and
we will create Universal basic
Healthcare won't cover very expensive
Cancer Treatments but it'll cover your
flus your broken bones and I'm going
okay that sounds pretty good and they go
and by the way we're going to give
children sex changes and we're going to
abort babies at nine months I'll be like
I'm gonna go vote for the other guy and
the other guy says no health care for
anyone but at least babies will live and
I'll be like I gotta take what I can get
I guess well what you just said is
what's called Obamacare right well
that's what happened under Obamacare
then they were mandated to pay for these
child sex changes and I think that went
into effect in 2015 and surprise
surprise that's also a year that started
skyrocketing now it's not just Obamacare
that's the year that Bruce Jenner became
Caitlyn Jenner yep and I believe it's
the year I am Jazz became a reality show
that might have started earlier but
that's helped to popularize this it's
been Jazz how long has it been on TV
it's like uh maybe it's longer than that
no maybe nine or ten years almost so
there's been breaks around there 2015.
but there you go oh okay 2015 yeah eight
okay
my my my statement is very simply when
it comes to liberals look man
I I would vote for like a moderate you
know I would prefer someone who's
moderate for for me
I can understand the arguments coming
from conservatives we have sane rational
logical arguments I often cite the
conversation I have with Glenn Beck on
abortion that was I thought wonderful
and ended with a handshake smiles and
we'll learn to live together and try and
find the best way to build a great
America and I'm like this is fantastic
and it was friendly and it was great and
I have tremendous respect for him and
then we have these people on the show
and these leftists who will say things
like I'm for forced abortion like
nonsensical
said that I don't think trans people
exist and I said who who are you talking
to yeah I was like what do you I I
absolutely think trans people exist I
don't what does that mean what are you
saying and like you don't think you
think they don't exist I'm like you're
not you're just saying words doesn't
mean anything it means nothing it means
literally nothing to me I I have trans
friends I think trans people exist I
want them to have civil rights I want to
be protected I just think we're talking
about kids here and there's a different
question so if my option is that or a
conservative guy at least the
conservative guy makes sense well and
this has happened on the show where I've
had this conversation with left-wing
guests and I have explained that I do
not use the made up pronouns I call
somebody a reality based pronouns based
on what they are and they were saying
wait so like you don't think trans
people exist conservatives don't think
trans people exist no I recognize that
there are human beings who exist who
identify as the opposite sex I'm saying
that doesn't actually make them the
opposite sex what is this slogan you
you're debating their right to exist
what no I can't I can't stop them from
existing with my words I can only
accurately identify what they are and
say I'm not willing to lie they say this
because it silences conversation yep
because it shuts people up it's the same
reason they say kids are going to kill
themselves if you don't let them
transition but here's the deal it's a
label right now an adult can take on
whatever label they want
but the way we should be framing this
especially with kids is there are
children with gender dysphoria or I
would prefer the word sexist for you but
whatever right there are children who
are struggling there's these are
children in distress half of them are on
the autism spectrum all these kids have
some other mental health comorbidity
going on they need to be screened for
trauma and abuse because that's very
common a lot of these girls and some of
the boys too have been sexually abused
some of these kids have come up to me
and told me stories there's always
something going else something else
going on and I don't want anyone to
believe me I want everyone to go onto
Google right now and look up a story by
Jamie Reed an article published by Jamie
Reed in the Free Press she worked at the
Washington University transgender Clinic
connected to St Louis Children's
Hospital she describes herself as a
queer woman who's married to a trans man
and she's politically left of Bernie
Sanders I didn't know that was possible
but she filed an affidavit with the
Attorney General of Missouri and she
wrote this devastating expose where she
confirms everything that people like
myself have been saying can I actually
wanna I wanna point something out so
recently we got news that Starbucks was
taking down the pride decorations this
came from the Starbucks Workers Union
and I posted about it and I had a bunch
of leftists tell me that I'm wrong
that I was hoaxed that the right is
pushing fake news and my response was
how did it come to be that the
quote-unquote left would side with the
corporation's spokesperson over their
workers union
it's wild it's probably tribal like they
just had literally yes
it's because the idea that they would
lose a culture War battle is more
important than the fact and I'm like
you know the thing me siding with the
workers union is on brand right I'm not
a big fan of unions but of course we
often side on the more populist side of
things the left tends to decide on the
corporatist side of things yet they're
supposed to be the ones that are working
for the workers it clearly just makes no
sense yeah they're the anti-fascists
they'll tell you they're not the ones
that are pushing the lucrative merger of
a state and all the corporations for the
record on this Starbucks thing Workers
Union said Starbucks is pulling trans
stuff Starbucks corporate said no we're
not and then there's video of specific
stores removing there's videos of
employees complaining they're being
forced to take down Pride decorations
but they're not saying it's by corporate
necessarily it's by middle management oh
they're saying corporate sent an issue
well I mean I don't think anyone gets
that specifically they're saying I was
told I had to take these things down so
it might just be the workers
micromanagement the workers union said
that there that across the country
they've been instructed numerous stores
have been instructed to remove their oh
and then corporate denied it and then
corporate denied there is no policy to
take these things down cool I don't
believe the corporate spokesperson like
when Deepwater Horizon happened and the
BP is like we're sorry I'm like yeah you
guys are full of it right I don't
believe when Fukushima happened and the
Japanese you know government they're
saying like everything's gonna control
like no you're lying right
what makes more sense a bunch of workers
were told to do a thing they filmed
videos about it they said it's happening
probably happening
but now you have the left on the side of
the massive multinational corporation so
no no they they never never said that
they're keeping it up it's like okay
whatever dude
yeah I kind of wanted to mention this as
well I mean the the left does back the
massive multinational corporations we've
seen this for a while they're not really
interested in workers rights and that's
something that's new in an overt way but
they've always advocated for policies
that enrich big business like illegal
immigration which we know just cuts
workers wages
Bernie Sanders in 2015 was against
illegal immigration and he was the left
and he had all the young progressives
screaming as loud as they can for him
but the official Democratic
establishment yeah but they're neolibs
they're corporatists they've never been
like actual socialists are left when I
say left I'm talking about the actual
left not the neolib well even most
left-wing people at least I've spoken to
through the course of my life have been
very much in favor of illegal
immigration and have argued that if you
oppose that you're a bad person who's
motivated by a hatred towards
brown-skinned people no I I can agree
with that but but also if we're talking
about like the there's also right
anarchists and Libertarians who are like
totally fine with illegal immigration
too yeah no you have that in the
libertarian party I'm just saying
overall we're talking about left-wing
right exactly we talk about left wing
and right wing people usually right-wing
people are against illegal immigration
or believe we need to actually enforce
our immigration law left-wing people
generally don't believe that but you're
you're right that it's not entirely
partisan there have been left-wing
people who have been on the other side
of that issue yeah that's my point is
but my point is this is certainly not
the first or only time we've seen
left-wing people come out in favor of
the position of corporate America you
know on illegal immigration it's
interesting let's talk about another
country for a minute Canada
yeah we're further left than the United
States for sure yeah we have no illegal
immigration and if we did people
wouldn't like it well you you do just
not it's not like as massive right yeah
it's minuscule yeah yeah it happens you
know I guess so I mean you have people
crossing the border illegally to get
health care yeah there's this place over
in Quebec where if you come through but
it's tiny but my point is
there's all this outrage from the left
in the United States because
they say well we need to stop we
shouldn't be stopping this we shouldn't
have a wall we should have millions of
people coming in guess what as soon as
you guys fix this one day and it will
get fixed
that's all going to go away there won't
be the outrage they just want something
to be outraged about they want something
that differentiates them from
conservatives and this is I think well
it helps them electorally too right I
mean because they know that if they can
fill certain counties or states that are
dark blue with many new immigrants even
if they're not citizens that increases
their level of representation so they
get uh more electoral votes I think it's
a lot it very much is people that are
miserable personally are lashing out at
the people around them and they're doing
it sociologically through stuff like if
you're playing a video game and your guy
keeps dying in the game and you're like
duh you're getting angry and then
someone walks into the room and tries to
talk to you and you snap at them like
that's like what this stupid like online
they're the bad guy they're the bad guy
like look inside of you how many drugs
are you taking to get through the day
like what's wrong with you that you need
to villainize your surroundings and the
people around you no God
lack of like stability because there is
no God in your life there's no like
Center Point like if you die it's okay I
mean I mean that's a hugely important
point it's a hugely important point
because with post-modernism with the
fall of traditional religions what do
you have you have a void
in
a a guiding belief system for how to
behave what to believe and wherever
there's a void that void gets filled
with something so post-modernism has
taken over this and it's there's no
purpose it's gender ideology right why
are we here what is what is the end goal
of anything I do if we just die when
it's all over yeah and the US of queer
theory is there is no morality
everything is acceptable right and uh
the only there they believe that there's
no truth but power right which is a
fascistic moral framework
because constitutional republicanism and
uh Classical liberalism like in the
United States we do not agree with that
we believe that there's an objective
reality that we seek to to better
understand and work towards yeah back in
the day if you disagreed with somebody
you would have to fight them and I'm
talking about a long I think Andrew Tate
was talking about this Patrick dueling
yeah basically and before that if the
tribal leader was said something was
real and you knew it wasn't either you
kept your mouth shut or you say you're
lying and then it would become a
physical fight to the death and whoever
wins is the one that gets to speak the
truth now and then if someone challenges
you you have to fight them but we don't
have that because power is not true we
do we as we don't really have that in
this Society you're allowed to disagree
with someone without fear of getting
attacked or having to fight them as Norm
Macdonald said I was looking back
through history and isn't it crazy the
good guys won every battle what are the
odds so that's a big problem Andrew
Tate's an interesting character now
before people attacked me online I
obviously don't agree with everything
Andrew Tate says it does however he is
filling a role
there are all these boys and young men
who feel very emasculated by this
Society
and right or wrong in how he does it
and Jordan Peterson as well so many of
these young kids look up to Andrew Tate
in Ottawa last week I was at this huge
protest that we organized and this man
came up to me he told me when he was
younger
he's probably in his early 20s now when
he was a teenager he came to believe he
was transgender that he should be a girl
he saw a psychologist three times three
appointments and the psychologist was
ready to send him off to get hormones
estrogen a friend of him introduced him
to Andrew Tate wow nice and he started
watching Andrew Tate's videos
and he rejected this whole hell yeah
mind virus that had taken over him now
he's working out all the time and he
credited he credits it to entertain so
Andrew Tate saved that guy's life to a
great degree yeah and then you've got
really interesting questions about why
they're going after Andrew Tate and his
brother he's not been charged so I
understand he still has not been charged
they're increasing the the potential
charges in the investigation but he's
currently be he was he was put in jail
then he's under house arrest not charged
for any crimes
very interesting and then you have these
women who are they claim were victims
actually came out and said we're not
victims we think he's great and then the
judge said no you're brainwashed yet the
anonymous the anonymous people that have
accused him have been totally fine they
continue to use those Anonymous people's
uh references and say that this is this
is totally reason to hold the tape
Brothers for as long as I have and
they're on house arrest have like the
little collars and such I mean they
should not have chosen Romania yeah I I
got to tell you like it's an awesome
country like I've been there and went to
really awesome Pizza Joint had a lot of
fun beautiful
but their legal system is uh not very
good he did like a five and a half hour
interview with Andrew with uh Patrick
Bet David on the pbd podcast I've
watched 40 minutes of it it's awesome I
highly recommend it but apparently he
just got served he and Tristan his
brother just got served with upgraded
charges so Andrew said but Andrew said
he met with whatever the person's called
district attorney whatever and that they
rearranged the charges to make them much
more minor but they're still charging
him but has he been charged formally yet
my understanding was that he was under
investigation but not formally charged I
think he has but don't quote me on that
um this says from today from CNN
um yeah served with legal papers by UK
lawyers
upgrading the severity of the
trafficking charge against him and his
brother oh a UK charge no I don't I
don't think so no because I don't think
he's been charged is this the CNN yeah
he's not been charged he's so they're
using the word charge haphazard the BBC
says they're expanding the case and the
investigation yeah right and my I I've
not seen it I could be wrong I could be
wrong but I had not seen any news they'd
actually ever been criminally charged
with any with any crime really a mess if
they think that you might be guilty for
some reason they're allowed to keep you
up to six months in jail and they kept
him in in solitary for first that's
crazy I don't know how he did it not the
whole time he wasn't I've been in I put
it I've been put in jail charged with
causing a disturbance for standing and
walking peacefully I was in there for
five hours in a Cell on my own
we're going crazy yep I was pretty
relaxed but my heartbeat was going and I
cannot imagine staying in there for a
long period of time because when you all
you got around he was White Walls and
they leave the lights on and you can't
he said the weirdest thing was like if
you get a thought like when did
Constantinople fall he couldn't he
couldn't figure it out he couldn't look
it up there's no way to like satiate
your your need for answers and so you
just got to live with the question for
like it I don't know he didn't say how
long but it just never goes away that's
how the world tries to be dude yeah
that's how the world
these people to ask somebody but like he
couldn't even ask somebody he'd just be
stuck there with his own thoughts I I I
my recommendation to everyone I've been
I I spent a night in jail one time
recipe for skateboarding is a funny
story because when I ended up going to
court for it the judge was so pissed off
they actually showed up too they charged
me with they tried charging me with a
felony but the cops were like are you
Nazi King like he's skateboarding down
the street you crazy but they were
trying to make an example of me skating
in downtown Chicago so they gave me um
criminal damage to a state support
location because I was riding my
skateboard down the sidewalk and so when
I went to court so I go to jail and I'll
tell you the story quickly and then talk
about Jill I go to jail and I was there
for I think it was like 16 hours I'm
there and not even it's it's a room the
lights are on it's a concrete block with
a toilet connected to a water faucet and
that's it yeah they took all the
shoelaces uh anything that they they
took my uh I think I had an over shirt
like I'm wearing now and they took my
shoelaces off my shoes and so I used my
shoe as a pillow and I just laid there
but uh I get out I ended up going to
court and uh the judge was like next in
the docket whatever everybody said you
know Timothy Poole and I stand up and he
was like so what's going on and then the
prosecutor standing with the the
security guys who had filed the
complaint said he was skateboarding at
this address and the judge looks down
pulls the guys and he's like he was what
and then he was skateboarding around and
he goes are you joking and then he he's
just like he said I can't remember
that's what he said but he was like get
in my courtroom all of you now cases Sol
which apparently means like they could
bring it back or whatever but it's like
we're gone this is a waste of my time
and then I was like can I leave and he
was like I'm sorry you can go and I was
like but anyway what I learned in that
uh half day in jail prison time is slow
was uh
don't there's nothing you can do
so six months probably substantially
harder than just doing a half day don't
get me wrong people have done way worse
but they have me in this room I could
hear someone screaming the door is just
a big metal door with a tiny little
window it was the light was on full
blast all night
it's a concrete block and so you just
have to immediately accept it
fighting thrashing panicking freaking
out only makes it worse you just have to
calm breathe meditate and take control
of your mind and then just accept it
yeah Andrew said his life training was
paying off and that you make your body
strong so that the outside world doesn't
destroy you and you make your mind
strong so that you don't destroy
yourself and he found the best way to
stay positive because it was just
constantly like what you're talking
about having to deal with it is to be
nice to the guards and to be nice to the
lady that would bring him a meal and
it'd make people smile and he said he
would make him always make him feel
better even the people that like looked
at him like they hated him started to
like him and there just started to be
kind of an uplifting energy in the jail
and that was what got him through it
there's a guy a Vietnam captive of his
captain that went down in Vietnam his
plane went down he got taken into a
hotel Hanoi where a lot of the prisoners
of War were kept in Vietnam and he said
everybody was just it was just misery so
he would do these smiling exercises with
the other prisoners just to like stretch
up and keep their their jaws and their
lips you know in a smile and that it
actually would would improve people's
moods that there's something about the
physiology with smiling I'll notice like
I look at like Mitch McConnell you'll
see a lot of like politicians and people
in power with permafrowns like where the
creases just go down what a miserable
way to live and I'll catch myself in the
mirror so I'm looking like that or we'll
just be on the show talking about
depressing stuff and my lips are like I
can see it on your face
so you constantly gotta like work it
it's almost like you got to force your
body to be happy no it's well there's
actually something to that uh you you
don't just respond to your emotions
physically your emotions respond to your
physical state if you if you improve
your posture or take on the pose of
somebody's more confident you actually
start to feel more confident if you
smile more yeah
happy they teach you this in uh
fundraising stuff stand with your feet
apart your feet align with your
shoulders and keep your hands open and
it boosts your confidence
that's why Trump does this if you're
doing a sales call you're supposed to
stand up not sit down yeah and walk in
they tell you to uh stand on the balls
of your feet and bounce up and down wow
yeah great when while you're pitching
while you're doing a sales pitch when
you're when you when you're pitching a
fundraise a a membership to a random
person they want your feet directly so
you spread your legs yeah I get that but
like that and then you're bouncing while
you present wow they want you slightly
bouncing and leaning forward wow uh
maybe because it makes you appear taller
energetic you know excited about it yeah
you believe in it but I I gotta tell you
I wonder uh I know people who have done
solitary like you talk about the January
six people two years or whatever so many
people in total lockdown
it feels like eternity it's like you
know it's the crazy thing
that uh about you know getting locked up
in a room where they never turn the
lights out you're in a building with no
windows so there's no natural light the
lights are on 24 7. you don't know how
long it's been you don't know what time
it is
all you can do is sit there you can't
it's it's hard to get tired when the
lights are on full blast
and so you're just sitting there staring
having no idea what's going on until
finally someone comes and opens the door
and I I think this should be I I'm you
know I think
it should be illegal there should be uh
mandated Humane treatment if you are
Presumed Innocent in this country that's
why I'm actually opposed to cash bail I
think cash bail is problematic but I
think that in certain circumstances
pertaining to a certain amount of crime
and uh the severity of the crime we we
should just have remand it's like you're
a criminal okay well if there's a
preponderance of evidence there's a chat
I think that people who are arrested and
charged should be given full life like
quality of life standards in jail
yeah I think the reason is because you
don't want people to get destroyed by
the process especially when they're
innocent you should get the internet you
should get a room the room should have a
comfortable bed a refrigerator a TV and
the internet you can't leave
you can go online depending on your
crime if you're like a financial
fraudster or whatever your accused of
that we're gonna be like look we're
going to restrict your access to certain
websites or something like that but if
you're Presumed Innocent why would I not
be allowed to work yeah well I agree
with you it's very strange right and you
understand why it happens just for you
know flat economic reasons but to be
subject to punishment before you've
actually had your day in court and
before you've been found guilty of any
kind of crime which you may not have
committed you could actually be totally
innocent is totally unfair I think it's
one of the Magnificent parts of the
United States because I don't think in
human history that's really been
considered that you would treat a
prisoner well I mean they they would
treat them well like especially the
really rich Dukes that they would
capture because they were going to sell
them back but like that you would give
the common man like adequacy in in while
they're waiting to be remanded or
charged or whatever that's it's pretty
fast some may argue we can't afford it
there's too many criminals and I'm like
well therein lies the problem of
Classical liberalism they just created
trillions and trillions of dollars out
of thin air
like the idea that we would give
everyone who was accused of a crime who
must be remanded a standard hotel room
is substantially more expensive and hard
to do you don't have to do that there
are parts of the world where prisons are
much more Humane right and it depends on
the crime you commit Norway women's
prisons are much more humane
because they're not usually in there for
violent crime well not even president
I'm talking about jail yeah right right
yeah jails are worse it's actually the
first holding facility to go to that's
usually the worst yeah I was in a room
with just like it was like a hallway
basically with two glass walls on each
side glass you know walls and doors and
they put you in there and you have to
stay there for a while and then take all
your stuff from you but if if we're
saying someone's innocent until they're
proven guilty
how are we then allowed to strip them of
their quality of life and punish them
before anything has been proven and I'm
a capitalist but privatized prisons
all it does is end up abusing these
people I mean don't get me wrong because
government-run prisons are bad too yeah
and but but we don't want to incentivize
the pipeline of prisoners but let's go
to super jets if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member so you can watch the uncensored
members only show coming up at about 10
pm it will be spicy it won't be family
friendly but uh it'll be good
conversation also if you click the link
in the description timcast.com mobile
Dash app you can download the timcast
Android app right now and start using it
so we're still waiting for approval from
Google and Apple
in the meantime you can download the
Google app we do have the Apple app done
as well but you can't just download that
to your phone the same way that you can
with uh Android so that's why I don't
like apple anyway let's read I'm not
your buddy guy says the mere fact that
every single evil person on the left and
right are uniting to stop Trump no
matter the cost just shows they fear he
will finally put an end to their
corruption and expose the Traders for
who they are
I agree
yeah I mean it's it's it's absurd to
think that Donald Trump who would not
invoke the Insurrection act in the
Summer of Love is somehow a fascist
dictator yeah I we talked we watched his
speech last night and after it was done
I basically hijacked the the talk
session that we were going to chat about
it and I I started to talk about Nazi
propaganda I felt like I got Twisted to
make it look like I was comparing him I
was just concerned about when you make
political speeches when people are like
talk about really depressing depressing
depressing things and at the very end of
the speech give a rally and cry that was
the point I was trying to make I think
Donald Trump has been an immense
um opportunity for Humanity in its
wake-up call and he's been a big part of
this like revolution of Consciousness I
have a lot of respect for what he's done
I got issues with his personality from
time to time as anyone would but mad
respect for the human being
I'm down looking forward to talking to
you really quick because we we it went
up uh I think yeah I downloaded it too
yeah people are saying it works great
all right Jesus believer says Tim and
Company if you haven't read the
blueprint by Shafer and Whitmore you
need to it breaks down the blueprint the
left has been using to flip States blue
well all right
hunter killer says the Kenyan President
says Africa is going to use afraxim bank
for trade instead of US Dollars America
is going to crash hard yeah yep and this
is and this is the question right the
reason why they want to make sure that
Trump doesn't get elected is because
Trump wants to actually uphold the
desires of the American people that not
have international conflict and War but
the reason one of the reasons they want
International war and conflict is to
force the use of the US dollar yeah yeah
I was just I mean I was gonna make a
cynical joke there about like I don't
know if the Dollar's gonna crash if
we're just going to go to war with those
people or both this is when you have to
find some reason a find some reason our
Freedom's over there if the pendulum was
swinging back I think you or asked us
earlier on the show I feel like the
pendulum is National Supremacy uh and
for the last 80 years it's been this
American liberal economic order that's
controlled the world and now the
internet has caused this backlash and
now the pendulum is like maybe
nationalist superiority isn't the way
but as the pendulum is swinging back
it's not on a flat plane it's not left
and right it's being pushed towards you
but people are trying to push it to the
left as it's going back and other people
are trying to push it to the right so
like how is the pendulum going to swing
back is it going to be someone like
Donald Trump that like upends the
liberal economic order is it going to be
something like a Communist Revolution
inside of the country is it going to be
a technocratic revolution will there
even be a revolution like will it end up
being a new form of American Military
Supremacy that's that's in the other
direction I wonder but I think
inevitably it is swinging back and that
people do not like American military
bases all over Earth pretending to be
like Global police or functioning trying
to work as Global police when you can
see the writing is on the wall most of
the world is not happy with the American
dollar being force-fed to it yeah
however I'm going to push back on that a
bit I've got a financial background for
18 years the entire world depends on the
US dollar being strong right or else the
entire world fails as well that's the
thing we all go up and down together
that's the thing about this a fraction
Bank thing it's it's not really it's not
really supported by a lot of things you
have to just convince a lot of people
especially in Africa to just suddenly
say oh we're not going to use are gonna
be saying I'm not our currency is a good
idea because of places like Zimbabwe et
cetera but I don't it's not backed by
anything there's no major superpower
backing that like there is with the US
dollar there's no there's no major
economy backing that like there's the US
dollar I don't think it's gonna just go
over just like that yeah when I got into
the financial business back in 2001 U.S
debt was I don't know two three trillion
something like that yeah now it's over
30. yeah that's correct and for the
longest time they were able to get away
with this because interest rates were so
low so your debt burden your interest
cost was very small now with interest
rates of five percent on 30 trillion
that's one half trillion a year what are
you gonna do you're getting pretty close
to the entire GDP of the country and as
we saw in I think 2000
eight
it was in Europe we had Greece we had
Portugal we had Iceland we had Ireland
right all about the default yeah so they
brought in these extreme austerity
measures now
they have huge taxes they have
consumption taxes we have goods and
service tax in Canada it's called GST
seven percent on everything same
Singapore there's nothing like that in
the United States there's still taxation
ability in the U.S but you guys can't
tax your ability out of this debt
anymore so it's simply a matter of time
until there's some sort of default right
yep and it's going to be bad what would
that look like well you know a lot of
the U.S debt is actually owed to the
Federal Reserve yeah yeah so it's like
they took money from their left pocket
and gave it to the right pocket
I don't know like can you cancel some of
that without having total a better
disaster of the third Detroit and the
Federal Reserve thinks we're going to
give it back we just give zero of it
back yeah we're gonna keep our money
thanks have you ever seen we just can't
keep going like this it's just going to
keep going I've ever seen The Three
Stooges yeah where uh they have the 20
Bill and oh yeah it's like you owe me 20
bucks and he's like well you owe me 20
bucks it's like okay here you go but
what's the books you owe me like so then
he's like okay now we're all even and he
puts the money back like there you go
you just do it that way all right the
whole financial system is
extraordinarily Fragile the whole thing
can come crashing down so way more
fragile than people that as we almost
saw in 2009 right raybert G Stanford
Junior says just downloaded the app and
it looks clean a lot of time for bug
fixing I suppose also have you seen the
new Tate interview he's quite the
Wordsmith uh I have not but I heard that
uh that it is up yeah Patrick David and
Adam sosnick went to Romania and sat
down at Andrew's house with him right
that's amazing five and a half hours he
was also on a million views he's on
Rebel today as well I saw it but I
didn't know Andrew was on Rumble today
yeah he uh went live it was a lot of
people that are watching on Rumble so
the uh the valuetainment guys are
awesome by the way shout out to the
valuetainment and David good dudes
they're doing really awesome stuff uh
down in in uh Florida yeah it's the pbd
podcast Andrew Tate you'll find it on
YouTube super cool yep all right uh what
do we got
Ryan fun uh fontanez says my wife works
as a production employee Target in
Indiana
and they had a meeting about the
employees being accepting to other ideas
boycott working wow Target very
interesting there it is super brev says
let me know if y'all would be interested
in having an ex Fannie Mae executive
during the 2000's economic crisis on
he's also an expert in economics Federal
Banking and Christianity uh yeah that
sounds amazing actually
yeah yeah that's wild absolutely so yes
but you didn't include a name yeah
name them
yeah name them and then we'll invite
them on
what are we at
Lego math again says Rittenhouse and
Penny are both Heroes who have taught us
the exact same thing get it on tape all
of our physical persons are now a Civil
War battlefield physical persons are are
Civil War battlefields of the woke cult
who seek to erode our basic rights and
assert their and Narco tyrannical power
over our entire lives
you know Tim if I may interrupt for one
second what do we do about all these
lying media companies
who just lie without any consequence
when you can but they're clever they
know how to bypass the uh the the the
the rules but they're the source of so
many of the problems in society
there could be no transgender craze
affecting children if not for the media
I mean it's not just that I mean there's
a lot like every Trump would not have
been impeached if it really wasn't lying
to I mean even right now uh you had the
story where Target was uh faced bomb
threats and almost all of the corporate
news outlets framed it as though it was
the right doing it when it was a left
Winger threatening them for pulling
Pride merchandise and so they they they
they they obfuscate these facts to lie
cheat and steal yeah
I mean look they're losing their ratings
are collapsing it's absolutely
incredible how um
uh CNN
Jake Tapper is like don't don't show any
more of this Trump stuff he he's lying
and it's just like you are so
ideologically captured you can't even
show the front runner for the GOP
you are so ideologically captured you
cannot show a former president give a
speech after a historical indictment
CNN's not going to exist in a little
while they can't even talk about the
news sooner or later it's going to be
like two left-wing activists talking
about how great each other are it's
gonna be it's gonna be two literally
like you're very smart no you're also
that's it all it will be because they're
gonna back well if we do talk about what
Trump is doing people get mad so let's
not do that
let's just talk about how great
sheamuses yeah let's do that I'm totally
fine it's tall thank you good looking
thank you oh my gosh you guys and I'm
super straight all right Andrew Roland
said someone make a Batman comic where
Batman beats up the Joker and Gotham
City tries to make Joker look like the
victim he wants to bring smiles to
Gotham and so police are forced to chase
Batman and arrest him I strongly
recommend Andrew that you read uh or
watch any of the Justice League
uh because they've they've done the
stuff I don't know about Batman Joker
specifically but um
there's uh I posted a clip from Justice
League Unlimited recently where uh and
this actually it makes it's perfect
context because this is actually what
the story was
Lex Luthor claims to be reformed and he
wants to run for president he claims
he's built lexor City to help
underprivileged people and deep beneath
this park where there are children
there's a machine with a timer going off
Superman panics fights uh Shazam AKA
Captain Marvel busts through the ground
and destroys the machine he was set up
made to look bad when he was trying to
stop what he thought was a super villain
planning to set off a bomb or some kind
of a device and you know he's gonna get
chased by the cops or anything but he
gets framed he gets made to be made out
to be the bad guy the bad guys like is
that the same story but the general idea
is you know they're going to make you
out to be the bad guy when you're trying
to do good anyway I posted this clip
because
should uh Captain Marvel at the time he
was called Captain Marvel not to call
him Shazam he's like I'm quitting the
Justice League and then Superman goes
he's right and then Batman goes they set
you up Clark and then Superman goes what
does it matter if it they and then
Batman goes they and then it plays
ominous music and I'm like the context
around that clip is very different 18
years later yeah you know yeah has it
been really been 18 years I can't
believe it's been that long while
yeah they now now if you were to say
something like that you'd be accused of
being a big an anti-seminine also other
crazy stuff but it was just like a kids
show at the time but there's a bunch of
stuff like that in comics where they ask
these questions and entertain these
ideas and they're uh they're they're
great I'm sure people who are fans of uh
DC Comics I mean after what is how long
has Batman been around 70 years or
something I think since the 30s 100
years 90 years old at that point yeah
all right let's read more
what do we got really now it's 1939 yeah
39 wow
so uh sorry this will be harsh towards
Ian for those of us who have been those
of us have been to war seen it firsthand
this is also the SD argument you have
presented when you say that you don't
know the details you are arguing to
argue the best skill is listening
oh okay no idea what they're referring
to that is the ultimate skill I don't
know what SD is
uh D claw says Tim and cast it was Prop
47 in CA that raised the felony for
retail theft of two thousand dollars it
was voted on and approved in 2014 only
during kova did people finally see the
effects of it in my opinion ah
interesting
it was supposed to be like a thing to
stop people being incarcerated for like
minor crimes and then it became this
massive problem that people still try
and say oh it's not true but like I've
been in La I've seen it happen in front
of my eyes many times this is what I'm
that's what I'm talking about there's
also 900 like come on I think I think
law is mostly meaningless mostly like
what the pro the problem is is no shared
moral framework true the fact that
someone is willing to steal shows that
they don't care about you as a member of
their community and they don't care
about the morals of society
it should be what what did Ron Paul it
was Ron Paul said I think it should be
legal but unthinkable let's talk I was
talking about abortion yeah
um I disagree with him there it should
be illegal and Unthinkable but on this
question of people stealing things part
of the issue here as well is is not just
um the fact that there's no longer Law
and Order massive massive party issue I
agree I I I'll also say that what's
happened is because we have moved away
from mon paw shops to just these massive
corporate conglomerates setting up their
stores everywhere people don't feel a
sense of brand loyalty and they actually
don't understand that they're stealing
when they're stealing to some extent
because they think this is a massive
brand that can afford the loss when that
isn't necessarily true for a lot of
these Brands uh the the profit margin is
Razor thin but because they're less
relatable as a massive brand it's it's
more difficult for people to see that I
think the employees also and middle
management tend to hate the corporations
that they work at if they work at like
I'm not going to call any out right now
but
um you know in the what are you with
that in the all the the retail industry
and stuff people don't really tend to
love the corporation they work for if
they're there for a paycheck so if it's
getting robbed it's like I'll be happy
to turn turn bad another round cities
also take Humanity away from people
because they're they're kind of
unnatural yeah we're supposed to know
our neighborhood I gotta tell you you
know I was giving a tour of the grounds
to uh a friend and there's
fruit everywhere we got mulberries too
many mulberries I can't eat them I'm
allergic we've got black cherries
everywhere they're not ripe yet we've
the black raspberries are now ripe and
I've been eating a ton of them we have
Allegheny Blackberry we have
um I just found this uh um what is it
called Greenbrier I think it might be
called there's berries they're not ripe
it either I've never heard of them I
don't know if you can eat them
apparently you can I don't know but uh
there's grapes everywhere Grapevine is
taking over everything nice and then I
was asked by my friend did you plant all
of this and I'm like no this is just how
the world is there is food growing but
you live in these concrete blocks you
don't see it
you know and one thing we haven't
touched on
Pharmaceuticals are destroying the
country I agree so many of these people
are on ssris oh yeah whatever and it's
just destroying opiates man let's uh
let's read some more we got jaded Soul
he says Jacker was on uh density
Destiny I'm assuming it was Destiny
Destiny a little while ago Jack said if
written writtenhouse was hit by a
skateboard he likely wouldn't die and
that didn't justify using a firearm what
an idiot also any chance on cast brew
coffee promo with Tim cast members
bought all Four Rise is fire rise with
Roberto Jr is insane I mean Jake has
said some questionable things some some
pretty unintelligent things but that
that is unbelievable did he really say
that I I have known jenk for a very long
time I do not believe he actually
believes these things yeah because
that's an insane thing to say there's
the idea that when you have a firearm
and someone else knows you have a
firearm and they hit you in the head
with a skateboard you shouldn't defend
yourself with that weapon If You're
Gonna Lose Control of it and this Maniac
is going around hitting people with
skateboards Gonna Take Your Gun and then
I'll have that yeah you'd be charged for
shooting him in Canada even if he came
into your house and did that that's
insane in every every province in Canada
yeah if someone breaks into my house and
I happen to have a
handgun which you can't buy anymore
they're illegal to buy or import or
transfer
I would have to actually be about to die
before I could defend myself otherwise
I'd end up getting charged that's that's
like the Soviet Union that's how it was
totally that's what it's happened in
Africa you know there's a town in Canada
or in America that's actually
technically in Canada but I think it was
due to like a map drawing error between
the two countries it the only way to get
there is by ferry
from Washington State you have to take a
ferry yeah or you can drive through
Canada for a little bit right you drive
through Canada and then there's like a
post where you walk in there's no one
there you pick up a phone and you call
and you're like hey I'm just letting you
know I'm an American coming in they're
like okay now I'm leaving but Roberts
Washington they do have a border
crossing now I go I used to go golfing
there once in a while
but it's a very small border crossing
dude when we so when I was like oh sorry
oh no no you go ahead you go ahead yeah
some of the NHL players like the Russian
players who played for the Vancouver
Canucks they'd go live in Point Roberts
because it was so close to Vancouver but
they had a lower tax rate because it was
Washington State wow yeah I remember
when I was a kid uh I was going to
Canada with my dad and my brothers and
when we were like going across the
border it was just a trip my dad was
taking my brothers and ion and they were
asking him all these questions was the
mother okay with you taking them he's
like my wife yeah she's fine they're
like do you have any written consent
from her to bring them to Canada he's
like I could literally just write a note
right now and give it to you why are you
doing this and the guy's like step out
of the car and they started asking us
questions like your parents ever fight
it was like oh my goodness when I went
to Canada the first time they uh the the
Canadian immigration guy said give me
your phone and I was like okay and he's
like unlock it and I was like sure and
then he started going through everything
and then he was like closing gave back
to me oh my gosh yeah I just like
through and they they looked in the back
seat and then waved at me and I just
kept going well so I I have several
phones and so it's like the phone that I
use on a day-to-day basis is not like my
personal stuff with my bank or my DMs or
anything just got like basic apps like
Twitter or whatever so he like opens
Twitter and he's scrolling through and
he's like I don't know whatever he's
like these are some pretty good hot take
sir he's like you're actually pretty
base too he doesn't say white supremacy
he didn't have the word based back then
all right let's grab another a super a
chat Tian says Tim have you have the
conclusion the end result is the
destruction destruction of cities that
is the side effect the end is to destroy
retail markets those that enacted the
lockdowns will make billions on Amazon
at all
what's this A comering cornering
cornering sorry yeah it looks like
cornering the online retail Market no I
don't disagree completely but I wonder
if the end result is literally just part
of the malthusian climate cult people I
think they want less people they want
you to eat bugs and they want you to
live in pods yeah I think that's going
to help I think right now what question
would you live in the Pod hear me out if
the pot could fly around Niles now now
hold on I would drive around in the pot
it feels more like a flying car than a
house but how big is the Pod we talking
like an RV type thing like van life but
it can fly or we talk and I it's like a
coffin no not a coffin like the Pod is
gonna be relatively small so like a car
okay so like a car is up in the Pod car
size spot so like the the driver's seats
fold down into a bed but it flies you
see the flying thing is super cool but
no there's just you can stand up in the
Pod and I had a shower and a toilet and
uh how would something like that fly
would you fly around it would just be
like so basically we're talking about
like a private plane that's an RV yeah
that's what they want you would you live
in a private place
they want everyone in private planes
trying to put us in private chats
everyone's got to live in a blimp
no this is starting to sound like a very
cool steampunk novel I think that using
vacuum vacuum density to fly is is
untapped when they realize the vacuums
are lighter than air we'll be flying
around yeah you know we should do we
should get like a hundred blimps and
then build a platform across all of them
so you can walk around on top of the
blimps and have a floating house very
small like a little sphere so if one of
them gets broken all the other sphere
vacuums will be keeping the system
afloat yeah I think we just solved
climate I think we can't afford not to
do it right that's right
we're talking about this they were going
to build a private City yeah no years
ago uh a bunch of Libertarians were
sharing this I can't I don't know if it
was a Libertarian who came up with it
but probably it was just a massive
floating city that would be in
international waters so you would never
have to pay taxes you'd just be a
citizen but they could also do crazy
research and development without any
laws or regulations oh that's horrifying
it sounds a bit like um like China right
yeah
City can go underwater yeah dude that
game was great
they really did not have a good view of
objectivists but you know the game was
still great I thought it was fun
what do we got what's this Joshua says
the app looks clean and runs incredibly
well so far awesome job timcast team now
to log in for members content so is that
is that not working we ran all the tests
and we've had tests running for months
and everything was working perfectly so
yeah I was asked to log in to watch
something and then and I had to go to
the website to log in uh
to sign up I now go to the website but I
don't know we're we're working on it
um send any issues you may have to
members at timcast.com I mean we just
started to put up because it works and
you can watch stuff and we'll get it
figured out plus we have you may have
noticed the beginning of this episode
The the advertisement for game of money
which is coming out next week on the
20th at 6 p.m and Ben Stewart is going
to be doing a live commentary in our
members only Discord uh for the first
watching so if you want to watch it with
him and uh you can ask him questions he
can answer them really excited it's a
documentary breaking down
all this financial stuff so uh
particularly relevant right now
pertinent to what's going on in the
world
I'm not your buddy guy says the Long
March through institutions it starts
with the elite universities and it
spreads to Future Leaders and Intel
agencies social media news Etc
yeah I think it's I think it's both I
think people that are these hard
Hardline socialist marxists Etc are just
seeing opportunity to use the useful
idiots to try and further their own
goals not necessarily that it's born of
Marxism I think it's just a convenient
time for them you see this this Super
Chat uh actually made my point Hanzo
says Tim the right are not cowards pause
I think they are they've been
conditioned for decades to not protest
Rally or speak the right are victims of
this conditioning too instead of bashing
the right for being cowards empathize
with them and decondition them I
specifically said that calling someone a
coward is not it is not my intent to be
derogatory insulting but people take it
that way because it is a negative thing
to be so if I say a coward is a person
who when facing fear refuses to act and
courage and bravery is when facing your
fears you decide to act regardless that
is not to say I am insulting someone for
choosing one or the other it is just to
say that someone is or someone is not if
they're right many of the people on the
right facing these problems choose not
to act out of fear for what may happen
to them that is the literal definition
of cowardice and I'm not saying that to
insult anybody there's just no other way
to describe it 100 there are though
situations where you would act not act
out of fear and not not counters like if
there's like a flaming pit to your right
you're afraid of it you don't want to
dive in but that doesn't make you a
coward because you don't need to go into
the pit if you need to then you're
coward for not doing it that's exactly
what my point was but we're not talking
about bullets and fire we're talking
about exercising your freedom of speech
because well we're talking about your
job okay your livelihood yeah your
friends your family social ramifications
like you can't get another job I look I
I agree but I understand that people
will be scared of these things but the
point is facing your fears is not about
arbitrarily facing your fears like
you know if there's like a hornet's nest
in front of me I'm not gonna be like
well I'm gonna be brave today and punch
that thing that makes literally no sense
that's just stupid now if there was a
hornet's nest that had fallen and a
friend of mine had fallen off their bike
and the Hornets were zooming past them
and then I'm like I gotta do something
about this but I'm terrified of those
Hornets
I'm not gonna let something bad happen
to my friend and I start running full
speed to try and help them up that is
bravery if I went oh they're gonna get
stung it's gonna be really bad but I'm
too scared so I better run away too
that's cowardice I'm not insulting
someone by saying you're being a coward
right not trying to insult someone I'm
trying to just State effect refusal to
act in the face of of necessity we've
had because there's times for a long
time and good times create weak men it's
true did you guys see the that streamer
had her car set on fire no what yeah
some twitch stream or some guy should
tour house and set her car on fire was
this uh was this Pokemon a while ago no
no this literally just happened the
story is like okay from this morning
twitch streamer yeah they said some some
stalker guy it's like
I understand why people are would be
scared and I understand why when
watching something like that or seeing
us get swatted so many times people
would say I am choosing not to act but I
but I think the literal definition of
Bravery is when you must and you are
scared you do and cowardice is when you
must and you're scared you don't I
suppose I wonder if these people feel
just don't feel like they must speak up
they're like it's not a risk my friend's
not about to get stung so why and so
they don't to them my pet peeve and
doing what I do has been all the people
online telling others that you can't do
what I do because
you'll get rape threats because people
will say mean things to you you've been
physically assaulted numerous times
probably 40. yeah yeah wow my arm broken
but that you know you don't have to do
what I do you don't have to go out at 7
pm on a Montreal Street like I did when
I got my arm broken by antifa there's
all sorts of ways to exercise your
freedom of speech in the United States
you can walk right into a state capitol
through the metal detector and stand in
the Rotunda of the state capital holding
your signs you can't do that in Canada
in fact if I go outside the legislature
in British Columbia even if I'm near
there with my signs they won't let me
into the restaurant for a few hours
after that you have to have a cool down
time all right we'll grab one more okay
clj says solitary confinement is one of
the worst punishments you can inflict on
a person had to do 48 Hours as part of
probation I was in the Cell by myself
the whole time felt like a week yep
especially when they don't turn the
lights off my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this YouTube channel
and share this video right now with all
of your friends if you like the work we
do you can go to timcast.com mobile Dash
app and download the Android app right
now and uh hopefully it'll be up in the
Play Store and the App Store on Apple uh
shortly but who knows it's been taking
forever unsurprising and uh you know
let's see how long that even stays up
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally if you want
to watch me do some super cool
skateboard tricks I just posted some
videos on Instagram at timcast and uh
again smash the like button billboard
Chris you want to shout anything out
yeah follow me and
please get educated about this and have
conversations because we're dealing with
each child abuse Scandal follow me on
Twitter at billboard Chris I'm trying to
hit 300 000 tonight same thing on
Instagram
and I've got a website
billboardchris.com if you want to
support me you can do so through there
right on
I make cartoons on a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes if you guys want to
check those out you can find me on
YouTube just at Freedom Tunes or you can
go to freedomtunes.com we're going to be
releasing a cartoon tomorrow about
Trump's trial that I think you all are
going to really enjoy uh I'm Ian cross
on everybody find me uh Ed Ian Crossing
on the internet anywhere I'll be out of
town for a few days coming up so I will
catch everybody next week good to see
you Chris thanks buddy
and I am search.com
um great show pleasure meeting you you
too we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in a few minutes for the
members only uncensored show thanks for
hanging out